two
all right
oh my God that this is a an emergency
broadcast
please everybody this is a National
Emergency this is not a test this is not
a drill we are under attack
our rights are under attack
free speech is under attack
fair use is under attack this is a
serious message with peace and love
peace and love
this is not a drill
our very rights our right to exist on
YouTube is under attack by Ryan
Cavanaugh this is the third lawsuit
against Me by an elite
Hollywood executive merely for
exercising My Free Speech my right to
have an opinion to Simply read articles
he's seeking to destroy me to
de-platform me to bankrupt me this is
not a drill
yes my friends this is an emergency
broadcast
[Music]
of the H3 podcast
and um I've got a lot to say to hear
today so buckle up guys
as you can see we've made some
modifications
to Ryan
I feel he's transcended into his um
his final form let's say
he's taken his human skin off and he's
become
Satan the literal devil the devil the
actual devil
this is a serious moment our rights are
under attack
the very essence of free speech
is under attack people this is very
serious
why why do I have this we'll get into
that we'll get into everything
all right I was supposed we were
supposed to have a family's reunion
today but
we had to we're delaying families to
next week
I'm sorry to everyone who's excited to
see my parents but this is important and
I feel like we need to address this now
at the top of the show
yes yes thank you thank you for first of
all thank you to everyone who's here
who's supporting us
this is very serious to be honest as
much as we joke and make try to make
Goofs and laughs out of this it is a
extremely serious situation
uh we do have sponsors thank you to
hello fresh and expressvpn
this emergency is brought to you by yeah
that was some serious [ __ ]
well thank you ELO
and you know what I want to say thank a
huge thank you to our members who
continue to support us in the channel
let's go members come on you guys make a
huge difference around here
come on members get episodes a day early
the pre-recorded and also
BTS special BTS every week by maybe live
performance by BTS
that's not true we don't offer that Dan
or do we
remember and find out sign up and find
out something called BTS
all right on the Reel though let's talk
about this so Ryan Cavanaugh
has filed his third lawsuit against me
we're we're applauding that
um he filed it yesterday he made a press
release he did all
he's he's
gone on record and said all kinds of
crazy [ __ ] and
um
I was extremely worried last night I'm
not gonna lie because the what's
different about this one is that he
hired this guy named uh this lawyer
named what's his name
I've been in here somewhere
douche McGillicuddy I believe is his
name douche McGillicuddy yep
well I had a I guess somebody erased it
it's douche McGillicuddy Oh Thomas
Claire so this guy I'm sorry so this guy
Thomas Claire is one of the country's
most he's like one of these big time
lawyers that specializes in defamation
and you don't this is my first rodeo you
don't hire this guy unless you're going
to war this guy's front this is like a
800 per hour lawyer who's like just
comes in sweeping his [ __ ] and just he's
like I'm here to [ __ ] your life up let's
go
so it's different in that regard it
feels way more serious
and scary
but I actually I finally got the
complaint
this morning
and it's all about Pond is it is it in
here
um
do we have the new complaint in here did
you put it you're the only one who has
it I sent it to I emailed it to you guys
I'll let it right now
yeah so it's all about the Ponzi scheme
which I when I saw it I was like this is
weird
there he's mad that I've kept reading
this article that was published by
variety actually you guys need to show
hold on hold on you guys need to show
oh never mind that's good you can't
really see the variety because that's
the way they printed it but variety made
this article and he's angry that I keep
showing this article
and it's like dude I'm just reading
variety's article like
how is that [ __ ] defamation now do
you know what I'm saying free speech is
literally under attack I can't read an
article published by variety he says the
article itself is defamatory so there
it's like okay we'll take that off with
variety
I'll show you guys the complaint right
um but anyway
the thing is he's been threatening he to
here actually here yeah we've got the
complaint here I'll
I haven't actually read it yet because I
just got it this morning but I skimmed
it which I'll show I'll I'll skim it for
you guys there's some
um
familiar images here
seems to be oh [ __ ] it's flipped bro oh
[ __ ] is this the trailer app or H3
podcast I think that's how they sent it
over
yeah what the hell well can you flip it
in um yeah we'll we'll flip it yeah
maybe I upload it upside down I don't
know man he got this no I'm looking at
it here it's it's a it was published
upside down it's very strange well
that's awkward
I can't believe they got this huge
high-powered attorney and they're still
flipping everything they do huh
yeah can you unflip it
okay there you go oh nice
yes so here you can see
hey look at this
here's a tweet I sent you know back in
July every time I think of Ryan
Cavanaugh I think of his business
partner alleging he was involved in a
Ponzi scheme it's like okay well yeah
here's the variety headline what do you
want from me
these are not my claims that's what's so
crazy I'm not claiming
that he ran a Ponzi scheme
variety is claiming that
well not even varieties claiming that
his ex-partner was claiming that right
partner his ex-partner retracted it
which we've made clear right but like
this is the headline of the article
still up it's still on variety
so and then he says I don't know if Jake
Paul here's another one from July I
don't know if Jake Paul left because of
Ryan Kavanaugh specifically but he
definitely thought Showtime was a better
opportunity than trailer so I'm not
surprised since the owner of Ryan
Cavanaugh was accused by his ex-partner
of running a Ponzi scheme as published
by variety
gotcha
again apparently that's defamation
um
here's a familiar image
you know Brian Kavanaugh running a Ponzi
scheme as Accused by his ex-partner
here's a here's every
here's every uh you know
every time they really went to Great
Lengths apparently huge huge fans of the
podcast apparently
you know
that sure looks fire though
yeah it looks good
you know
keeps going huge fans of the podcast
someone's been watching every episode so
we appreciate that
um here I am pointing to it
during this exchange a producer held up
this photo in the background
huh oh yeah
that's UAB oh yeah I'm a producer baby
you know uh oh and then the the shirt
which this is just what he wrote govern
yourself accordingly
and this I think is Andrew Santino it
looks more like Andrew centino than
anyone else
so I don't know what that's all about
again we never sold this
scam accused of Ponzi scheme by
ex-partner you know
Ponzi scheme so here they include this
on the website that we made does
Ryan Kavanaugh look like Harvey
Weinstein and here if you read it it
says Elon Spar signed a complaint under
oath alleging that Kavanaugh persuaded
him to go to into business under false
pretenses the lawsuit was resolved out
of court the story was covered in June
7th 2019 Variety article Ryan Kavanaugh
Accused by expert on a running Ponzi
scheme okay how's that defamation
somebody [ __ ] please tell me how
reading an article
is defamation
yeah so they're very he's very sensitive
to this headline
uh okay so this is a comment he received
unrelated to me by the way
I guess um Ryan Kavanaugh is like a huge
uh Zionist whatever that means well I
know what it means you know
um
I I don't want to put words in I'm
pretty sure he's like a huge advocate
for like the state of Israel's yes
whatever you know
but if someone said uh what was the
Tweet he said because I remember it was
something
kind of inflammatory it was kind of like
a bad take maybe you guys can find it
from him yeah a bat hey you'd have to be
more specific what well look up this
tweet and then find out whatever he
tweeted
because they this person okay who's not
associated with me it has two likes they
include in the complaint defending a
genocidal ethnostate cringiest thing
you've done since allegedly running a
Ponzi scheme
they even say allegedly
they don't even [ __ ] like by the way
I didn't leave that comment I don't know
if you guys know that or not Emerald I
isn't your uh your sock puppet well
according to Ryan every account on the
Internet is my sock puppet I'm the
Puppet Master
and then I said when you think of Ryan
Kavanaugh what comes to mind I'm sorry
red hair
uh a movie producer relativity media
relativity media trailer like what the
[ __ ]
you know peop people say Ponzi okay well
take it up with them
I didn't you know exactly I didn't write
that
again now they keep trying to blame me
for [ __ ] on the subreddit Ponzi scheme
up vote this post so when searching for
Ponzi scheme Ryan Kavanaugh shows up
again this is the subreddit I don't post
this [ __ ] bro this is like one of the
main tenants
of the internet is that by the way and I
don't own Reddit either
wait do you know that you don't post
that I read an article yesterday saying
you do yeah Ryan's article which we'll
get to okay
more comments more Twitter responses
this one has a hundred likes so you
could see you know it's hard to recover
from a tweet with a hundred likes
somehow this trailer showed up in my
feed after some investigation I came to
realize the creator of this even has
bankrupted his previous companies well
that's true
has been involved in creating a Ponzi
scheme and has an uncanny resemblance to
Harvey Weinstein well that person
actually
apparently forgot to mention that it was
retracted but again I'm not them so I
can't force them to
put in every little [ __ ] disclaimer
that you want you know
oh okay and now he's get he's getting
nasty messages and is unfiltered
Instagram DMs like do you want do you
want me to scroll through my Instagram
DMS and show you the death threats I get
every day
okay some dude named is I don't actually
I'm not trying to dox this guy I don't
know who it is but like someone someone
tweeted him kill yourself in Instagram
DM
and he's [ __ ] acting like
this ain't 20 21 dude I know you just
created an Instagram account like three
months ago but I'm sorry to tell you
that you'd be getting this with or
without me I guess I did something to
piss off the Instagram God oh yeah you
did
anyway
um
I'm just browsing and looking at the uh
the images here
they keep showing the same [ __ ] I don't
know what that's about
why am I saying the same thing twice
they flipped their complaint oh no
so there you have it okay oh oh it looks
like they did
oh they flip oh it is flip [ __ ] yeah so
that's actually breaking news I wasn't
ready to present this today so I just
wanted to kind of show you guys what was
in there and it's actually almost
well I haven't read it but it seems
entirely about this Ponzi scheme article
the variety wrote
that's still up and it's really
interesting that he's so sensitive about
this this Variety article
let me pull it up
it's like it really
it really bothers him this article
because like he says
he's like look at this
he says oh it was immediately retracted
it's like well here's the title you know
there's no [ __ ] correction in the
title like variety didn't think that
whatever he said was important enough
to amend the title and by the way
um
he also we learned sent a bunch of
of uh threatening defamation lawsuits to
people who reported on this The
Hollywood Reporter article which we'll
read says that he was on the receiving
end of Ryan Kavanaugh
litigation threats so this is a
litigious man who's used to getting his
way in every single regard through
privilege through litigation through
threats and sometimes even you know
well it is what it is here so here
here's the update
right Kavanaugh
wait so there's not even update below it
just says update below that's all they
wrote
so variety
thought that his correction and threats
were um important enough because he says
all they say is update below
so you have to go all the way to the end
of the article to get his statement an
update okay
which is hold on
where's his where's his updated
statement
bro I think you're you're in it update
here there you go Kavanaugh and Spar
appear to have mended fences
rep sent a statement Friday afternoon
saying they are satisfactory resolved it
the statement also accused Variety in
The Hollywood Reporter of having
attempted to smear both Kavanaugh and
Spar by quoting from their lawsuits
against each other
so this is the delusions that we live in
the next line is even better lawsuits
against each other which they say they
submitted to the court by accident yeah
whoops that how the [ __ ] do you submit a
lawsuit by accident a lot of my hands I
guess when you when you do so many
lawsuits you just keep track you lose
track of them oh there's too much I'm
suing every person who left a mean
comment on Twitter oh I tripped and it
accidentally slipped into the clerk's
office and we accidentally paid the fee
to file it yeah like my credit card and
the file anyway so you so again like
he's saying like I didn't do my due
diligence like this update is not
[ __ ] that easy to find what you see
is a fat right Kavanaugh Accused by ex
partner of running a Ponzi scheme fat
huge [ __ ] title and then update below
okay
anyway let's get into it let's get into
the whole thing
I really hope that more people take
notice of what's going on here I'm happy
to see that The Hollywood Reporter
finally covered this story and I think
that Philly D is covering it today he
reached out for comment to me today I'm
really really happy that more people are
starting to cover this and I hope more
people will because what he's doing is
nothing short of like Scientology
level of legal harassment
I mean this is his third lawsuit against
me because he doesn't like being
criticized period he says it's his first
lawsuit against you yeah well we'll get
into that as well
but I hope that more people cover this I
hope that you know this gets in front of
more eyes and more reporters and more
public interest and I hope that you know
because this is a he this this is a lot
of ramifications
for for free speech
and fair use which I think people keep
forgetting because people had so much
energy the people were so passionate
about the first lawsuit with Matt Oz
um
and they and this is the same thing he's
saying I cannot watch a clip of theirs
period that's fair use guys if I lose
that it's gonna [ __ ] over everyone
and I'm not gonna lie I was scared last
night I would [ __ ] barely slept I was
so worried man
because of the super lawyer they've got
and this is the third lawsuit and it's
just
it's like this [ __ ] will never end He Is
Dead set
on [ __ ] my life up but on you know
it's like
what can I do I got to do the right
thing it's the same thing that happened
with the first lawsuit I could have got
out of it for four thousand dollars and
ended up [ __ ] over two years of my
goddamn life
and now here we are again now I'm
already in like a quarter million
and it's probably going to cost me over
a million by the end of this
assuming I don't
lose if I lose then God knows how much
money I'm going to owe them right
don't like to think about that but I'm
doing this because it's the right thing
to do okay that's it that's the bottom
line This is fair use this is First
Amendment this is the [ __ ] it I'm not
giving into some bully some media Elite
who has endless troughs of cash to throw
at harassing and silencing me I'm not
gonna do it it's not happening
I Will Never back down from you Ryan do
you understand you're a bully
and I don't like bullies
and I will never back down from you
I will spend every [ __ ] dollar that I
have to
and
that's just what it is bro
I don't like it again I tried to resolve
it I tried to pay him to go away in the
beginning
you guys got to remember how this all
started because Ryan's trying to paint
himself out to be the poor victim this
started okay when I found out I was
being sued
uh by by the way keemstar once again
apparently a champion of
um
apparently a champion of fair use right
and and Free Speech
celebrating
that I'm being sued by a huge Media
Company
for copyright infringement when I was
clearly fairly using it okay
so here's the statement I didn't know I
was being sued I found out from keemstar
Trailer filed legal action on April 23rd
in the U.S District Court against the
owners of the H3 podcast website for
piracy
they say that us and dozens of other
sites re-streamed and profited
from as many as hundreds of thousands of
users each so okay right out the gate
Ryan's coming at me like lying saying
that I restreamed
his event which is a blatant [ __ ] lie
okay
more than 2 million illegal streams of
the event occurred on Jake Paul okay
well you know we we again like I have to
restate the facts because Ryan is trying
to spin this [ __ ] like crazy we didn't
even react
to
the event until five days after the
event was over so you exactly tell me
how the [ __ ] I took away PP pay-per-view
views from you when I didn't even react
till five days after the event
in the case of the H3 podcast they
specifically are calling me out
trailer added the site to its legal
action after the site owner admitted on
his podcast that he pirated and shared
okay that's a [ __ ] lie I said I
personally as an individual watched an
illegal stream
if you want the 50 bucks
that's fine but to say that I shared it
is a blatant [ __ ] lie the legal
action could result in civil fines up to
150 000 per illegal stream as well as
potentially 250 000 in criminal fines
and up to five years in prison oh yeah
and oh yeah and then keemstar and all of
his goons go Ethan's going to prison
going to prison for for using fair use
like these guys don't even know what
they're celebrating
yeah we love that precedent of someone
you YouTuber going to prison
for fair use
like there's they hate me so much that
they don't understand what they're
actually [ __ ] celebrating stupid
[ __ ] if I remember correctly FaZe Banks
corrected keemstar on their own podcast
and it's like you know he's not actually
going to jail right like that's thank
God yeah that's what I do I yeah yeah of
course it's like
yeah well there so the fines are
calculated at 150 000 per instance so H3
podcast basically owes us like 10
billion dollars according to them for
every podcast view it had a million
views so what's uh let's see here so
according to them what's 150 000 times a
million uh oh 150 yeah thousand times
one million
yeah that would be uh 150 billion
dollars yeah so there so you know
expected damages 150 billion dollars
yeah Jeff Bezos is like I can't pay this
I can't afford to pay this legal uh
okay so right up the gate you guys have
to remember as we go through this this
was a shot across the [ __ ] board this
was a shot heard round the world against
me okay the uh one of the biggest
proponents of fair use champions of fair
use on the internet a threat of putting
me in jail and finding the 150 billion
dollars okay so you guys want to say if
if Ryan wants to pretend like he's the
victim let's remember how this whole
[ __ ] thing started
okay
and then you have to also consider that
I was at the time not wanting to get
into another lawsuit I was handling uh
settlements amicably I offered them you
know like I don't even remember Ryan
claimed in a statement we offered him 50
000 I don't remember it may have been
fifty thousand twenty five thousand is
what I remember whatever to make this
just go away just say [ __ ] off they
demanded in response when I was being
amical amicable
they demanded a million dollars and a
statement
a [ __ ] statement
to be read on the podcast
where's that statement you guys got to
read this yeah
so they they sent me this say they said
you have to read this on the podcast
now you tell me if this is someone
acting in good faith
can you highlight it for me please it is
right here thank you
so they say no you have to pay us a
million bucks and read this statement
okay
so they say
in light of the foreground we hereby
reject your clients offer for 25 000 and
counter proposed settling this matter
for nine hundred thousand
and the agreement to make the following
statement okay now you guys listen to
this and tell me this if this is in good
faith
we are pleased to announce that we have
reached a settlement with triller Fight
Club
as a result of us pirating this event
Thriller surprisingly has embedded
Watermark technology unlike anything
we've seen today why do I think that
Ryan wrote this himself is literally
written so
[ __ ] terribly and it's who even talks
surprisingly triller has surprisingly
has embedded Watermark technology unlike
everything I've ever seen
you and I mean it's everyone knows that
you are an expert on Watermark
technology and so because I'm a pirate I
know how to dodge watermarks right but
you've never seen anything quite like
this before anything like this to date
surprisingly it's not flipped
did this offer yeah no it's not upside
down I mean the technology surprised
that's not in the
and then it goes on I have to say we had
a million dollars to settle we had to
pay a million dollars to settle in order
to avoid 50 million or more in potential
liability
we encourage anyone who pirated the
event to take triller's amnesty offer
very seriously wait what
they they're asking for nine hundred
thousand dollars and then the statement
they want you to say a million yeah
exactly they're asking me to lie in the
[ __ ] it's so weird
we encourage anyone who pirated the
event to take triller's amnesty offer
very seriously and to pay the fifty
dollars before what happened to us
happens to you
triller's incredibly serious about this
and we do believe they will find most if
not all people who pirated by the way
how's that going yeah I'm sure I'm sure
they're really rounded rounded everybody
up in the Paddy Wagon by now so do you
see how psychotic this is I make a good
faith offer to settle and they say no we
need nine hundred thousand dollars and
for you to basically read the most
insane statement that one could ever
[ __ ] read me being a fair use
champion
a free speech champion
this is not this is basically them
saying [ __ ] you we're coming after you
this is Spite and uh so so again who's
the victim here I have never sued
anybody in my life
this is pure aggression
from Ryan Kavanaugh
okay so I think it's important to
remember
how we got here
before we continue
to reading his new statement and let's
not forget Ryan Kavanaugh sent me a
threatening [ __ ] DM on Instagram
in July
Ethan I am not sure why you've decided
to take upon yourself and show on your
show to malign attack and slander and
defame me I do not know you I also don't
know why you are spending thousands of
dollars to have thousands of dummy
accounts post fake statements about me
on my Instagram and tens of thousands to
have fake app reviews on trailer it's
like bro self-report like I'm not the I
don't know how much it costs to pay Bots
but apparently you do what does that
mean foreign
worst yet you dedicated an entire show
of yours reading your own fake reviews
so what
well they're not fake reviews first of
all your own as in yeah the ones that
you wrote yeah he's like you paid all
these people to do fake reviews and then
you read them on your show yeah I don't
pay people to write reviews bro
I saw a really funny meme on the
subreddit where he's like wait you guys
get paid to do this
yeah maybe you can pull that up if you
see it I thought it was funny yeah we're
not paying anyone there's no fake
reviews okay
while amusing and slightly annoying at
best I would advise you to stop and
mitigate your damages now your toy
podcast again
I feel like that statement really
reveals what Ryan thinks is that we're
just some stupid little [ __ ] kids he
can kick around and spit on because
we're not serious business tycoons like
him your toy podcast seems fun and all
but this is real business with real
consequences and you are causing real
damage
okay well so are you [ __ ] you're
[ __ ] what are you doing
this is a business
yeah
in America lost I checked we have a
freedom of speech and fair use well this
was America
I mean this isn't true I thought this
was America moment
and then he goes on clearly you are very
unhappy and Disturbed
to take it upon yourself to attack
someone you don't know with false and
misleading information especially to
spend tens of thousands of dollars on it
but it must stop again like he's so
obsessed with the fact that I have to be
paying people and that people actually
just don't like him or his app
and also why are you going on to call me
unhappy and Disturbed like you say I
don't know you well you don't know me
either dude
um you know what
uh you have been warned and I will not
be threatened and aligned in standby
idly govern yourself accordingly so
let's just remember where we are here
okay and how we got here this man has
threatened and bullied and intimidated
me from the very [ __ ] beginning of
this
with that press release
you know
here he is this was kind of like he
started tagging me on Instagram
here's my here's my notifications I
started getting DMS from Ryan Kavanaugh
because he kept tagging me
so this is what this is how my day
started yesterday why I suited sued
Ethan Klein with him tagging me now
check this out look at this little
statement at the bottom
h3s reproductions needs at he tags me
needs to stop harassing harming and
attempting to destroy other people's
lives
spreading false and malicious lies
apparently reading headlines is
spreading false and malicious lives
unfortunately it looks like I'm going to
have to be the one to stop him I believe
within months his channel will be banned
from YouTube so that is that tells you
everything you need to know this is an
elite
Hollywood Tycoon who when faced with
criticism has set it upon himself to
de-platform me from YouTube
which is the same kind of [ __ ] Matt Haas
was saying by the way
you know this is the same [ __ ]
he continues tagging me by the way
um his article and then by the way it's
funny that he's like oh you're sharing
headlines like he's doing the same
[ __ ] thing
I'm not about to sue him you know uh
Ethan client he keeps posting this same
headline like Ethan Klein accused of
racism and homophobia
you know this is stuff I've addressed
this I've I I I honestly this was from
two years ago it was extremely offensive
the things I said and reflection I
deeply regret those comments and the
people I offended and you know I stand
BTS now I've I've educated myself I've
listened to the music I love BTS and the
BTS community and I absolutely [ __ ]
regret I'm horrified and disgusted
by the comments I made and I still to
this day apologize
and stand the BTS community and Army in
general you know
so like if you're trying to parade this
in front of me like I'm gonna be
embarrassed or something I mean while I
deeply regret it I do hate this I loathe
to see it and to think about it because
it's just it's humiliating
I'm okay I'm always okay talking about
it and facing my demons so to speak
facing my my uh
my fuck-ups right because I always think
I'm never gonna try to hide from things
I've said or done I'll talk about as
many times as I need to because you know
what people shouldn't say the things I
said and um if I can talk about it and
change the discourse even a little bit
by bringing it up and talking about and
facing it head on whenever it comes up
then that's what I'm gonna do I can't
hide from it
so like you know
but it's like do you even care about the
issues that you're bringing up like why
are you using this offensive moment as
like a cudgel against me do you actually
care about the offensive things I said
were you offended are you just using
this because you think it's like a
tricky little Pawn in your game like you
obviously don't care about these issues
it's just
a headline
and so I just think it's like
disingenuous and very [ __ ] gross of
him to just be like oh well look Ethan
once said something racist and
homophobic so uh not that I care about
that stuff at all I'm just showing I'm
just doing I'm just trying to show a bad
headline about him do you know what I
mean like doesn't it feel like just
weird and sincere when people are like
they bring up stuff like that it's like
well you don't even care about that
stuff so why what do you [ __ ] care
assassination of character
so anyway
he's now he's now taken upon himself to
post
head mean head or well post negative
headlines about me and tagged me on
Instagram
you know pretty psychotic
um
he also said to the bet so here's here's
the other little Wrinkle in this
this Wikipedia user
who says he's Ryan Kavanaugh
and I actually believe it is Ryan
Kavanaugh for the following reasons he
said this user said
that he was filing a third lawsuit
against us next week that was the first
and only time I had heard that and sure
enough the third lawsuit comes out which
relates me to believe that this user is
in fact Ryan Kavanaugh of course it's
not confirmed though just to be clear he
said um I have he said that he's
complaining to Wikipedia editors
I have pressed much more recent and
copies of the legal actions against H3
for attempting to disseminate these very
same falsehoods if you would like to
review them as well as copies of the
legal complaints sent to YouTube which
ultimately resulted in them being banned
with two strikes for a week and now
hopefully permanently twitch is also
reviews reviewing the same info for a
band so why this is important is because
once again it proves that Ryan Kavanaugh
is trying to de-platform me for
criticizing him he is sending legal
complaints to YouTube to get me strike
to get me banned permanently banned and
also twitch for no [ __ ] reason other
than to just de-platform me so that if
YouTube does suspend or ban me then I
won't have anywhere else to go
like twitch like I've done I've not even
broadcast any of this [ __ ] on Twitch
he's fully going for the full cancel
here he says my page is Ryan Kavanaugh
so you know what I'm saying also the
user is RK and he's been the the user's
been editing the Ryan Cavanaugh page a
lot so there's a lot of reasons to
believe that this this person is is
actually Ryan but again it's um
unproven but you know
so again he is not the victim
this is a Non-Stop sustained attack on
me my livelihood and my right to free
speech and fair use
from the very Inception of this legal
battle when you put out that press
release it was an all-out war on my
American Rights
my god-given rights as an American
citizen
yeah so you guys want to read this
article finally
because
this article he publishes a [ __ ]
roller coaster bro
yeah he then he posted this as a little
teaser before the Dark Side of social
media you know what I find ironic Ryan
Kavanaugh is the figurehead of triller
the dark side of social media is not
like young women uh unaliving themselves
or people you know the like how dark you
know people getting sucked in losing
their self-confidence becoming obsessed
with their online Persona no that's not
the Dark Side of social media the Dark
Side of social media is this one guy
saying mean stuff about me
like how out of touch can you be bro
that's the Dark Side of social media
is Ethan saying mean stuff about me
and this guy's in charge of triller he
wants to be the new tick tock and just
to show you how in touch this guy is
like you think this guy's actually
ethical and responsible enough to head
actually he is he'll fit right in with
Zuckerberg and
he'll run it about as good as Zuckerberg
what we really need to worry about on
social media is people is this one guy
Ethan
I'm gonna meet you
tomorrow I will be publishing an article
that speaks to the harm and damage
irresponsible people like h3h production
can cause through social media once
again tagging me it's time for some
changes for someone to put a stop to
people who use their social powers to
intentionally harm others
how about you using your status and
money to [ __ ] try to stomp me out of
existence through the legal system
for the first time I can say I am suing
h3h Productions this boomerass [ __ ] puts
a URL
and Instagram description which is not
clickable
and then the final the cherry on top of
course
is before I read this
is that
okay so this is [ __ ]
this is when [ __ ]
this really tells you all you need to
know okay
I actually here let me pull up the
Instagram post it's it's linked in the
dock I have a highlighted if that's
easier
know sweet faster
so I posted a nice picture of me and my
family my son on Thanksgiving
okay this should tell you everything you
need to know about this guy I posted a
nice photo of me and my family on
Thanksgiving Happy Thanksgiving
love you all so much so thankful for
everyone family crew audience so
thankful for all I have peace and love
Ryan Kavanaugh goes back to this post
this Thanksgiving post
of me with my son
um
and links the [ __ ] url unclickable
url
under the [ __ ] photo
someone said did you really just comment
this under Thanksgiving family photo
Jesus Christ dude you are sad
this [ __ ]
went to my family photo
and linked his URL
congratulations Ryan Kavanaugh you are
our showman of the year
right I just wanted to remind everybody
that this is what he was doing on his
Thanksgiving while you were spending
time with your family was posting 10
year old articles about how cool he is
and Crossing out the date
wait what is it what is this you keep
sending he's he actually said so yeah
someone commented on one of his posts
yesterday
um I put in the doc and he responded by
saying that you got popular uh from a
podcast where you ate your own poop
I did
not that I recall
the exchange is pretty average he says
it was really good and the interview you
did really sold it people come from the
H3 pod and thank Gary douche when you're
just doing your job they just got to
give you a chance solid guy
yeah
right well we suspected that okay
whatever I'm not good so he says thank
you anyone who blindly follows that
guy's just clearly has a lot of hate in
them and that's bro you're the one that
came to my family photo on Thanksgiving
and posted the article with my son in it
has hate in them and has too much time
on their hands to listen too much time
bro don't get me started bro
so this rambling nonsense and troll
people after all he's a guy who built a
podcast on eating his own poop
and making racist homophobic and
xenophobic comments classic episode hold
the [ __ ] phone you don't remember
that that was epic when you did that can
you he's a guy [ __ ] live on air he's a
guy who built a podcast on eating his
own poop
that's your thing
is that deformation it sounds a lot like
defamation unless you have some footage
of you eating your own [ __ ] on the
podcast that sounds like some defamation
it's all true you guys foggy memory or
something all right happening does he
mean the old h3h reproductions video
that's the only thing I can think of but
so the foot soldier that sent me this uh
suggested that maybe he mixed up on
after dark 59 we were talking about Nick
uh Nick acoto [ __ ] himself but how's
that he says he get to eat it that is a
stretch yeah I don't know it's got to be
the the old H3 video but that video is
so old and I'm pretty sure I removed it
I guess they've been trying to do some
like Recon to try to pick up dirt it is
remote maybe the eat the poop that's
from like seven years ago I made a video
with Frank filthy Frank where it was
there was some challenge going on and we
said oh it wouldn't be fun if we did it
eat your own poop challenge just to show
how stupid all these challenges were and
I had like a melted Snickers that I was
pretending was poop from like seven
years ago right shot in my small
apartment but like to say I built a
podcast on eating poop I'm assuming but
but like it's so weird he's doing deep
research and that's what he dug up this
is he's a big fan that's been my theory
all along he's actually a big fan and
he's just hurt
isn't he also a Barbie or was that
someone else
a Barbie a Nicki Minaj
Barbie
I don't know
Stan culture is getting to Ryan
Cavanaugh it's true
that's a weird comment yeah someone
asked if that's defamation and he said
no I believe it's called defecation on
himself smiley face
oh that's funny but it's also is
defamation because I don't know what the
[ __ ] you're talking about
that's defamation by the way talk about
too much time on your hands you're
arguing with people on Instagram
followers I don't even do that and
apparently I have a toy podcast with all
the time on my hands in the world
no it's called defecation on himself
what are you talking about
got em that's a Zinger Ryan good job I
pooped my pants I'm gonna sue you [ __ ]
you said I eat my own poop
yeah well
[Laughter]
by the way so just to clarify here about
this this was I would say it's
unconfirmed but like so the user sent it
he BL after tagging me all day he
blocked me which may have removed his
comment on my post or he deleted it
right because we couldn't find it we
couldn't find it last night but the guy
who screenshotted it sent it to us and
it does look real
but it's I guess I should just say it's
unconfirmed oh wait is he talking about
like my first ever video see that's what
I was thinking
that he went I sent you a really deep on
you wait he's really went back to my Mr
President video and he's saying I built
my podcast on eating poop
yeah whatever
I mean that was the first domino in a
way I guess I guess it's a chain of
events yeah
I wouldn't say I wouldn't say I built my
podcast on eating there may have been
some intervening events after that but
yeah oh man I want to sue him for that
just to see their evidence
I want to see the discovery
yeah I mean that's caused real damage to
me saying that I eat my own poop yeah
it's a huge reputational head
what is otherwise a sterling reputation
on the internet absolutely
well you joke but I come on now
don't say it like that
okay so
um let's read the [ __ ] statement I I
went to Great Lengths basically
to paint the picture because what he's
he's trying to paint himself as the
victim
I've gone out of my way to harass and
malign him it couldn't be further from
the truth this man from the Inception of
this
has come out unreasonable unwilling to
compromise attacking me
and threatening free speech and fair use
so here's the article
by Ryan Cavanaugh
coming out with some hot hot clip art
that we were able to find it's just some
royalty-free [ __ ]
here actually we found where the clip
art came from
here it is guys if you want to use it I
should use it in my own article against
him
it's called mail hand holding megaphone
from which the Hydra comes out
the metaphor of slander and evil speech
I have chills I'm wow so epic this is
the metaphor for slander
how did he get his article published in
the extremely reputable
periodical that we all know csq.com
story with substance power obviously
power and influence csq I mean what the
[ __ ] is csql
season quarterly could you imagine a
more [ __ ] douchebag
place to well he's putting them on the
map csq baby
this is a huge breaking story for them a
huge exclusive all right here we go the
dark side of the power of social media
why I Ryan Kavanaugh sued Ethan Klein
and his H3 podcast that's actually the
sound it's making
today I sued Ethan kleim he has lied to
his followers and the public and
profited from it I was left no choice
but to do exactly what he told his
millions of fans I did prior and sue him
I I haven't been able to figure out one
lie I've told on this guy all I've ever
done is read headlines that people have
written about him
on April 17 2021 trailer a company I
have an interest in
and helped to found put on a boxing
match between YouTube start turn fighter
Jake Paul and MMA fighter Ben askerna he
keeps trying to diminish his rolling
trailer but if you look at every
interview he's ever done and even the
bottom
of his own [ __ ] article it describes
him as the co-founder of triller
so I don't know why he keeps trying to
pretend like he's got nothing to do with
trailer and every time trailer has an
interview or anything it's always him
he's like represents them in every
interview
um
so it was one of the first events of our
new business trailer Fight Club
following our initial foray into the
fight game the November 28th fight
between Mike Tyson and Roy Jones Jr
which sold 1.6 million pay-per-view
fantastic
the Paul asker fight was successful but
not as successful as it should have been
Thanks to internet piracy we estimate an
excess of 4 million unique views of the
fight were stolen at the price set of 50
bucks that equals more than 100 million
in Lost Revenue so okay
right off the bat
he's setting the stage for me being the
sole reason why uh his event with Jake
Paul and Ben askren let's [ __ ] be
honest bro Mike Tyson versus Roy Jones
Jr we really think that ball that you're
going to get as much revenue from that
fight
[Music]
he's setting it up to where ice
basically ruined his business and once
again I think it's important to claim
that we didn't even cover this
Pay-Per-View event until five days after
the event pirating pay-per-view events
is not a new phenomenon well it's
illegal it usually a single person
pirating for their own viewing we
offered an amnesty to those who did that
simply pay 50 bucks and we would not
come after them
unfortunately in this case podcasts like
H3 and Ethan Clyde didn't just pirate
the event for personal use instead they
rebroadcasted to millions of people not
only resulting in hundreds of millions
in Lost sales for triller but money made
for client through his own ad sales and
sponsorships which he sold against
trailer's pirated event yeah that's just
a straight up [ __ ] defamatory lie and
that's why I spent so much time pre
pre-looting this is because he he he
just he's trying to flip the script
change the narrative and make it seem
like he's this poor guy that I'm trying
to ruin his business all I did is the
same thing I've always done since the
first time I was sued for copyright
infringement and one is reacting to a
short clip with critical commentary the
podcast was like three hours long and we
watched like a few minutes of their
three-hour broadcast five days after the
event and somehow I'm responsible for a
hundred million dollars in Lost Revenue
their event was like four hours long
right yeah we reacted to a few minutes
even a minute I mean I I'm not super I'm
not I'm not gonna say because I'm not
familiar but it was a short amount yeah
I mean
like the content for him to be like oh
yeah we we made money and sponsorships
against it like we did a super long
podcast that day and this made up like a
fraction of our podcast
but also we didn't rebroadcast it we
just watched a short clip of it dude
so what the [ __ ] he's lying
yeah and so like if people aren't
actually familiar with the facts if you
read this then they'll be like oh [ __ ]
this guy Ethan
the truth is he targeted me from the
beginning
I think I
my my guess is because I said that I
pirated it
and that pissed him off and I always
have this theory that keemstar was
somehow involved in it they've been
talking I I'm serious I mean it's just a
theory it's speculation yeah we have no
idea yeah we can't say for certain but
whenever FaZe Banks was pressing him and
saying you know Ethan's probably not
actually going to go to jail keem's like
I don't know I've been talking to people
who I don't know we'll see what happens
and that was pretty I think I'm kidding
but there was a picture of him coming
out of trailer headquarters there is
keemstar having the press release and
posting it there's all this like you
know keemstar has this dossier on me
that he sends everybody like Ryan's got
all the greatest hits
I know it seems far-fetched and maybe it
is it's just speculation obviously
but he targeted me specifically for a
good headline and because I don't know
why I'll because I really don't know why
he thought it'd be an easy dub I think
in an ideal and fair world it would be
YouTube's responsibility to stop this
Grand Theft
now this is a whole new can of worms
like let's get oh yeah other big
channels showed the fight too and
weirdly He never [ __ ] targeted them
he never tried to sue them he never made
a press release calling them out by name
right why
huge channels YouTube channels
some with more than double the amount of
subscribers
why were why were they not targeted
so he says it would be YouTube's
responsibility to stop this Grand Theft
instead current laws make it trailer's
responsibility so right now and this
should concern you he is saying that
there's this what is the there's this
specific law that allows is
yeah
this guy is so [ __ ] dumb
there is a law
that
allows forums where people post content
to not be held responsible for what
people do and say on that it's like
section 230 or something it's a huge
that's exactly it's section 230. okay
and YouTube Facebook Reddit even triller
which is why this is so ironic wouldn't
be able to exist
without this 230.
because they would be held liable for
whatever the [ __ ] anyone on their
platform did which mean they'd be sued
into Oblivion they would cease to exist
that's why I find it so ironic that Ryan
is somehow advocating for that which
would basically make triller impossible
to exist so weird
what an idiot
the owner of pirated content must
identify and Report the thieves which
trailer did with Ethan and H3
in turn YouTube can take several days to
investigate and then maybe take down the
pirated stream which it did it didn't
he never reported us we never got a dmca
request he never did any legal notice in
fact there was someone who re-uploaded
the whole [ __ ] fight and as far as I
know it's still up on the on YouTube
section 230 provides immunity to social
media companies like Facebook and
Twitter against being sued over content
on their site this allows them to
operate in flourish without needing to
moderate content exactly
there are tons of videos I'm not going
to play it obviously yeah but uh
yes it is uh one of the most interesting
things almost a million views over a
million views and it was published in
April so uh so that this is the most
interesting thing to me about
this case is that he never made an
attempt to remove the pirated content
from our Channel or the people who
re-uploaded it and put it on YouTube as
far as I'm aware the law requires and
copyright that you first make an attempt
to remedy the situation through DMC or
something else which they never did and
he's saying here
the owner must identify and Report the
thieves which Schiller did with Klein in
H3 I can tell you right now I had never
got a dmca request
in turn YouTube can take several days to
investigate and then maybe take down the
private stream that's also not true when
YouTube gets a dmca it comes down
immediately
the guy doesn't understand what he's
talking about but by then it was too
late everyone would have purchased the
event had already watched the pirated
event and the pirates in this case H3
and Ethan were enriched at trailer's
expense once again a [ __ ] lie we
didn't watch this event until five days
after the peep the Pay-Per-View event
are you telling me that people were
buying tickets to this Pay-Per-View
event five days after the event so it
was two what was it too late for
it was too late for you to make money
from this event you have it backwards
do you see that he is intentionally
[ __ ] misleading and lying about me
and the facts of the case
everyone people would have purchased the
event and already watched the pirated
version the Pirates in this case Ethan
Klein were enriched at triller's expense
liar [ __ ] liar
that whole thing is just a c
of slander and lies
in the words of keemstar
I'm in a sea of slander and lies
yeah
so once again you know if you don't know
anything and you read this you'll be
like wow that's [ __ ] up you know
in the entertainment industry a great
deal of a company's value is in its
intellectual property that's ironic
considering he's being sued for stealing
the Triad the three
the triangle ring
protecting a Pay-Per-View event is
exactly the same
as putting a fence around a factory
or placing an armed guard inside a
jewelry store
if a burglar broke into a store and
stole millions of dollars of jewelry and
resold it they would be prosecuted this
is no different and how it harmed
triller which spent tens of million
dollars making this product yeah I mean
that analogy would work if I stole the
event in its entirety and re-uploaded it
to YouTube or so resold it or something
like that that's not what happened
[ __ ] I reacted to a brief clip
that's called fair use [ __ ]
it's part of the first um it's part of
[ __ ] free speech
you don't have a right not to be
criticized
after the Paul asker and fight triller
identified several other businesses and
individuals that pirated all or part of
the event and focused on those who
actually profited off the piracy such as
Klein and his company h3s3 Productions
again they from the beginning they've
tried to make it sound like I like
resold and I remember in the original
complaint they said that I was like had
a Paypal link and I was accepting
uh payments to watch it and it's just
[ __ ] such a lie such a lie
late in April in the U.S District Court
for the central district of California
trailer filed suit
included in defendants was the H3
podcast run by Ethan Klein and his wife
uh Ela under h3h reproductions e-look in
Easton Klein after their alter egos I
don't know what the [ __ ] he's talking
about but I think he's referring to how
he is suing Teddy fresh how if you guys
want to
here here's my proof that he's just
legally harassing us like Scientology
why did he Sue Teddy fresh
Teddy fresh is a separate
and distinct legal entity that has
nothing to do
with H3 podcast why is he suing Teddy
fresh
foreign
so someone want to explain that
Brian
anybody
else Brian in the chat
hey
you're getting nervous man he claims
that Teddy fresh is our alter ego which
I guess what that means is it's just a
shell company to hide assets like
dude what the [ __ ]
yeah self-report
right I wonder what kind of alter ego's
got going Proxima media right look into
it
well well you should walk that back a
little bit
just proximate media I just said look
into it well okay let's look into it
we're not saying the proximeters alter
ego but he does have a habit of
self-reporting that's speculation Dan
that's okay dude what the [ __ ] do I know
you're supposed to be the one keep me on
the rails
he's got a company Proxima media you
know you guys are flipped go off King
what'd you say me I said you guys are
flipped today you're keeping him on the
rails right right I know our rolls are
flipped ah Ryan got okay I was like Ryan
got into the Ryan got into the Mainframe
ah get Ryan out of this ah I'm flipped
okay thank you
we got a flip button here today
H3 is broadcast on YouTube and elsewhere
I mean okay elsewhere
trying to make it seem like a big deal
it's just podcasting RSS feeds
not only did H3 and Klein profit from
the stolen ppv
but they also bragged on their podcast
about pirating it I mean yeah I said
that I personally as a person
viewed a pirated stream because I didn't
want to support Jake Paul who was being
accused of essay
in the New York [ __ ] times wasn't it
I'm pretty sure
yeah it was the New York Times the paper
of record
so I made a conscientious objection to
not support them because I wasn't didn't
want to support Jake Paul it was a
personal decision I made
not an office in my home according to
them I can just pay them 50 bucks for
amnesty but no
triller not me filed a lawsuit to stop
and hopefully recoup the financial
damages that had been done to the
company the piracy allowed the clients
to make a substantial amount from their
advertising and sponsors off stolen
property like I know what you're talking
about we just did a normal podcast it
wasn't like on the corner of slinging
tickets to this exclusive event
like literally by the way he keeps
saying like oh well they're lying it
wasn't me that filed the lawsuit the
reason we've ever even named him is
because his lawyer told our lawyer that
Ryan Kavanaugh was personally behind the
lawsuit
he was trying to intimidate us from the
very get-go saying Ryan Cavanaugh's
behind this lawsuit so you really don't
want to [ __ ] around with us
and also in one of the lawsuits they
allege that we defamed Ryan Kavanaugh
for saying he looks like Harvey
Weinstein
so how is it
that you're not involved in these
lawsuits
stop trying to act like a little [ __ ]
kid stop using low baby [ __ ] logic
we're not stupid
maybe we are a little bit stupid but not
in that not that stupid not that stupid
initially Klein seemed to be interested
in a settlement okay thank you
but against all common legal practices
rather than negotiating good faith he
disclosed his views on the suit and the
terms of the discussed settlement on his
podcast to millions of viewers and
further despairs triller
which included his offer to pay 50 000
to trailer what's wrong with that
against all common legal practices it's
like okay I talked about it I don't even
know where he's talking about because
it's like this Behavior breached
multiple litigation laws Okay so
No it didn't
also
I mean
we'd have to go back and look but this
this explanation that
you shared the details of the
negotiation
um that only happened after the
negotiations broke off that's how I
remember it too you were you were
purposely staying low-key about all of
this as it was all playing out and was
only once
the decision was made okay I guess the
lawsuit's happening that you started to
talk about on the show so that's how I
remember it too yeah and so it's just
another intentional misrepresentation of
the truth and outright lie
to make me look like the villain
um
yeah it's like he showed him bad faith I
mean I remember saying on the podcast
that I was like I want to handle this
amicably so let's just see how this
goes and it was only after they told me
I have to make pay nine hundred thousand
dollars to make that statement where I
was like well I can't do that so [ __ ] it
you know what I mean yeah I was
definitely not operating in bad faith
absolutely not
if anything they were with that [ __ ]
settlement offer
since that time Klein has only escalated
his juvenile reactions well I take crops
with juvenile I'm a grown-ass fan
he has posted video after video
attacking and slandering me personally
despite the fact that I while I am a
shareholder and co-founder am not
triller
okay
you are not trailer as a person
he says I am not Thriller I am not an
officer I'm not CEO
he says I am a co-founder
I am not unilateral decision I do not
make unilateral decisions for children
nor did I personally sue him okay well
that's not what your lawyer told me yeah
I was gonna say talk to your lawyer then
yeah
but at the same time it's like
you are you have been involved in these
lawsuits you have sent me threatening
messages on Instagram you have named
yourself in these lawsuits saying I
defamed You by saying you look like
Harvey Weinstein you have and also every
time I see a trailer press conference
it's always Ryan Kavanaugh speaking on
behalf of triller
you know like
and when you type your name right
trillers Ryan Kavanaugh's big comeback
I'm sorry bro but this argument stinks
Klein understands how search engine
optimization works and is titled his
pure Isle videos
to show up when my name is searched his
Legion of followers has Amplified the
attack by the way he accused me of being
some like CEO genius I literally just
type his name I just put his name in the
title of a highlight like Ryan
Kavanaugh's new whatever that's not like
SEO magic genius
mad genius
although we it's just
it's like
I don't know what the [ __ ] you're
accusing me of he has blackheaded his
way
by putting
Ryan Kavanaugh is suing me oh that's a
[ __ ] black hat
we need to take him up with Google
thank you
I'm an SEO magician
among other things he has posted more
than eight podcasts disparaging me
though he has never met me again he
keeps saying that like I'm sorry bro
what why do I have to meet you he gives
a [ __ ] yeah I don't want to meet you
yeah I've read enough headlines about
you to know that you're a terrible
person
not someone I'd ever want to meet or
associate with
he's never spoken to me
he does not know me
only people that know me are allowed to
criticize me your honor
he does not know me well and so it is
defamation
people that know me well all love me
your honor
they would never say a bad thing about
me
through these podcasts use spread false
information which he knows to be false
and has done only with the antenna harm
he keeps saying that but he's not saying
what what false information all I have
ever done is read headlines of reputable
organizations
that's all
that's all I've ever done my friend
all I've ever done is read headlines of
reputable
news organizations
if you think those are defamatory then
take it up with them
pull up some headlines Dan
we've shown the Ponzi one from variety
how about the DOI ones posted in the New
York Times
I mean
financier in Hollywood strikes deal in
DWI
is this
defamation to read a headline
scroll down
that's what's that that's all right grab
it off in the New York Times
scroll up a little bit
Mr Kavanaugh's arrest in the fall of
2006 was followed by months of legal
proceedings during which the financier
argued that he was unlawfully detained
by the police officers who accused him
of having been the driver of a vehicle
that took off after hitting their car
the New York Times
laughs
you see it is that defamation it's
probably annoying to hear this right
it's kind of funny yeah Chad kind of
likes it I think it's funny but I don't
want people to be like it's starting
that's funny okay next article
how about the babysitter one
how about the
fabricating a memo
Hollywood exec sued by babysitter and
waste spot
Fox News
[ __ ] five
you know
Hollywood producer and financiers being
sued by former babysitter for his
newborn child who alleged she is owed
more than 175 000 after he abruptly
fired 2020 only two months after into
her 13-month contract Ryan you gotta pay
the [ __ ] up when you sign a contract it
means you gotta pay
so the one where he forged a
document against his then ex-president
am I now answer me am I creating any
allegations am I making any claims no
I'm simply reading headlines this is
from deadline
relativity fabricated memo claiming
sexual harassment against former
co-president Adam Fields judge Awards
Fields 8.4 million go to where it says
cab
after a forensic audit
of the computer was conducted it was
found that the memo had been generated
by someone who signed it as Captain
is
I would guess uh Ryan Kavanaugh had it
guys it's a wild guess
captain
I've not created this crank these are
things you have done
that's pretty [ __ ] insane thing to do
by the way to forge a document like
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
so
again this is [ __ ] why this is
important this is
right to my this is at the very heart of
what
our rights are
is me reading headlines defamation
absolutely not
do you understand how insane this is
this is Scientology
this is legal harassment
he doesn't like that I'm talking about
all the shitty things he's done I am not
creating these claims out of thin air
this is a bad dude it's well documented
and it's all been published by huge
[ __ ] media companies if you have a
problem with what they're saying take it
up with them not me
none of those articles were published in
uh
c-suite quarterly which is the only
source that I put any variety so you
know
New York Times isn't c-suite quarterly
but it is considered for the most part a
very strong reputation fake news fake
news so is variety Hollywood Reporter
Fox News
c-suite quarterly that's that's it
I trust I thought it was like a
community newsletter
I didn't I've never heard of it prior
you've never heard of c-suite I honestly
thought it was a community newsletter
the [ __ ] wrong with you dude reporting
wait what you're never gonna be in the
c-suite you know that you're never going
to become a member I have a membership
what's the membership by the way
you can become a member the Professional
Network and online reputation amplifier
wait
[ __ ] yeah I mean this is obviously
wait it's just a service you pay for to
amplify your reputation yeah he well why
would he post it here it's like a weird
self report so he's gonna post this
who's gonna carry this [ __ ] [ __ ]
also that's the thing is so he I I would
Hazard a guess this is speculation that
csq does not have like an editorial oh
you don't think this was fat check no of
course not I mean it wasn't vetted no if
you wanted the New York Times does that
yeah of course and you know they're not
they have a strict audience but I mean
yeah they're gonna they have a strict
editorial process yes an editor is going
to look over and so for them to print
something like Ryan Kavanaugh got
arrested for doing a DUI Hit and Run
that's what the police officer said they
would vet that
uh certainly yeah
especially against someone as litigious
as Ryan Kavanaugh
maybe we should we publish something in
csq
let's sign up oh that would be [ __ ]
epic well I did write a big statement
which I'll get to okay that I've been
looking for a place to publish in
response to his and I'm I think csq is a
good place but I was thinking of
publishing it at does Ryan Kavanaugh
look like Harvey Weinstein oh that has
that's about as reputable as csq yeah
which I think is a great hub for
hard-hitting reporting
absolutely oh speaking of which he gets
he talks about it here
he has created a website comparing me to
Harvey Weinstein resulting in further
false articles and sites to be published
and directed traffic to these farce
articles and sites okay once again
he's totally misrepresenting what this
is
this is not we did not compare him to
Harvey Weinstein indeed okay we
literally and the website's name is
basically says it all
the website by the way here's his
article there's a redneck does Ryan
Kavanaugh look like Harvey Weinstein and
the URL itself debunks his claim
okay
it's all about appearance only a lot of
our viewers and people's notice in
general that he strikes a resemblance to
Harvey Weinstein
and so we built the website does Ryan
Kavanaugh look like RV Weinstein to
basically help the public
right tell the two apart if anything he
should be thanking me right that's a
great point I'm not comparing him indeed
in fact I have explicitly gone out of my
way to say Ryan has never been accused
of you know sexual misconduct this is a
comparison and looks only
so to put that out there like I'm trying
to you know malign him in that way like
look at this
is just absolutely [ __ ] false now
you're making sure people know that it's
two different people that's what I'm
it's a public service
we're actually now number one on Google
in very many places uh I've heard
reports that were number one on Google
in Australia for example oh in Sweden
rule number two no that's it that's
super interesting so like that to me
says that Google has recognized our
website as having valuable information
right because Google is the Premier
search engine Google has trillions and
trillions of search results and they
identified our website as the most
relevant one so I mean people want to
know
yeah clearly people want to know well I
mean here is him kissing Harvey
Weinstein on the head and when you see
them side by side it's really confusing
so this is a horrible Monster Who's in
jail and this is Ryan Kavanaugh a
horrible monster who's not in jail
horrible monster for very different
reasons than Harvey Weinstein not sexual
crimes and he's not been even accused of
any sexual crimes but when you see them
side by side buddied up kissing each
other and stuff like that then you say I
just want the public to be like okay
that's
Ryan that's Harvey correct hey you got
it I got website's working
yeah so I just want to say for the
record I I don't see the resemblance
yeah I know you said that a lot but the
people disagree with you
there's even a test there's even a game
you can do if you guys haven't seen this
we built the game caught anybody coming
out of the house yet but so you can test
your skills
it gives you you know three two one why
am I hearing Wendy what's going on it
says it's just hard to be around is this
on the website
yes oh so I think it's Harvey so there
you go I got it right nice one nice one
so anyway we built the game out and I
think I'll I'll publish my statement
here anyway
great choice
um
oh oh AB found something interesting I
could be mistaken so let's just preface
this way oh it just says Pro oh so it
says advisors profiles yeah so according
to this page Ryan Kavanaugh is
oh an advisor
that seems like a biased
interesting place to report your of
course of course oh nice find oh that's
so [ __ ] funny he's on the board of
this magazine that published his uh well
he's an advisor maybe yeah advisor yeah
according to this
so I mean you know that's awesome that's
on the side that's so [ __ ] funny
anyway let's continue it's just
important for me to You Know cover
everything
he created a website comparing me to
Harvey Weinstein resulting in further
false articles and sites to be published
and directed traffic to these false
articles and sites I don't know what
you're talking about people say you look
like him I'm debunking that yeah and
again directed traffic to these false
articles your issue is with the false
article
I think I think he's I don't know what
he's saying I think he's take it up with
[ __ ] variety man
he has sent this is where he's just
straight up lying he has sent paid
traffic to the site to push it to page
one of Google search results for my name
[ __ ] you have no evidence you
are straight up a line we have never
bought traffic again a self-report like
I'm sorry bro you cannot just make
statements like that and [ __ ] lie I
have not bought paid traffic
I have not
that's defamation he's lying he has no
proof of what the [ __ ] is this
you want to talk about defamation what
are you saying
he has encouraged people on Reddit
YouTube Twitter and Instagram
and elsewhere to click on this site
upvote comments and encourage to keep
pushing it higher in my search results
listen bro I'm not Google I don't
control the search results okay
I'm just a man who's trying to clarify
um when I look
yeah so I go ahead look I I worked with
SEO before for this job and so I took
the liberty to search through Ryan
Cavanaugh's personal website and
allegedly you know nothing nothing is
for sure this was science of paid
increased rank Google ranks so I saw in
like backlinks to like spam websites to
promote his website basically so he is
actually allegedly the one
well exactly and everything he accuses
me of is that's based on your expert
opinion it's allegation it's on
substantiated there's no proof of that
it's just a speculation based on Love's
expertise but
like it all is a self-report everything
he accused me of he knows because he
does it
but to just blatantly accuse me of
paying for traffic is psychotic
a client has instructed and encouraged
his followers to attack my social media
channels no
which they have going so far as
threatening me and my family if I don't
leave Ethan alone I've received so many
threats negative messages vulgar
comments from Klein and his followers
from me that I've been forced to
restrict commenting on my social media
um
I have at every turn said do not go
harass Ryan Kavanaugh do not engage with
him on social media we are fighting a
important legal battle and going and
sending him your comments directly is
not productive it's wrong and I don't
support it
and I have never done that and I have
never encouraged anyone to do that and
just a reminder he's the one commenting
on your Thanksgiving post with your
child and your pregnant wife harassing
you by posting links to this article
exactly maybe yeah allegedly
uh and well also well one thing he has
for sure been doing is hitting me up in
the DMS posting
right tagging me and showing up in my
stories right uh he has posted and
reposted a misleading Variety article
with a headline that includes the phrase
Ponzi scheme to him to imply that I was
involved in fraud he has posted this no
fewer than 30 times
I'm assuming he's just including every
podcast I've done with this so it's not
like I've been posting it but
okay if you don't like the variety of
article take it up with them
again not my [ __ ] problem dude I
showed the article like it's it's still
up
it looks just like this well minus the
hell goatee and stuff
you know
uh Klein never mentions that the content
of Oracle is actually debunked in its
own headline that's the weirdest thing
like again if you open it
I have by the way mentioned that's been
retracted many times in fact there's
even a highlight of me saying something
like a correction for my lawyers or
something what was it called
yeah so he says it's debunked and the
he says Klein never mentions that the
content of the article is actually
debunked in its headline where no no no
no it says debunks its own headline oh
debunks its own headline yeah
okay well isn't that a problem with the
article then don't like talk to the
author also see no I'm not a lawyer am I
not allowed to show a headline but also
debunk I mean
the fact that they retracted it does not
necessarily mean that he his ex-partner
didn't accuse him of running like his
ex-partner did accuse him exactly and
then later retracted it but the
accusation happened yes
and that's the report that's in the head
like it doesn't just magically disappear
from history because he later said oh
never mind I'm not going to pursue this
legally we we settled that you know they
settled it behind the scenes that's what
that's what the update is right is that
they came to a settlement or they came
to an agreement of some kind but the
accusation happened I mean that that's
that's something that did happen at one
point yeah by the way I'm I'm gonna put
Discord on the screen can I put this
because I want to show the thumbnail or
maybe you just pull it up but
it's called a correction for Ryan
Kavanaugh and it says here I'm just
going to show this here I made a mistake
okay
there it is
to say that I've never
even commented it once again
play and lie
a correction for Ryan Kavanaugh
I'm out the [ __ ] bro
so the Arcos headline refers to a draft
complaint that was never filed it was
filed it was just so this is real
interesting because the The Hollywood
Reporter wrote an article about this
just came out yesterday which I'm going
to read after this
the article refers to a draft complaint
that was never filed while the article
itself quotes all the parties involved
denying any allegations of fraud dude
that is so not what the article says bro
what happened it's really kind of
complicated and interesting but
basically the media gets access to
complaints before the lawyers do
and so what happened was they did file
these
the the media got it wrote articles
about it it can take a few days for the
lawyers to actually get it
so by the time the lawyers got it they
had already resolved it behind the
scenes right but they did file the
lawsuit and the media reported on it
yeah it's the only way that they could
even know about it so the fact that you
know he's trying to make it seem like it
was never filed and stuff is very
weird it's like this weird thing where
they they did file it and they're trying
to pretend like it never existed I mean
take it up with [ __ ] variety I didn't
write the article again nevertheless
Klein continues to do everything he can
to harm me my business and trailer by
flogging the inaccurate variety headline
and disregarding the factual content of
the article lie client states I don't
pay my employees I didn't pay my nanny
this is falsely misleading again we
showed the articles
client has posted I have two DUIs also
false I'm just it's the New York Times
bro take it up with the New York Times
well he wasn't convicted of two DUIs he
was arrested twice for DUI and then one
of them was mysteriously reduced to what
was it wedding right wet and wild went
wild it was wet and wild
yeah yeah a uh a rich Hollywood producer
you know driving drunk allegedly and
Hitting and Running allegedly somehow
mysteriously having his charge reduced
and by the way when he hit and run
allegedly the second time he was already
on probation for the first offense right
and this guy's not in jail
yeah I mean do you have a driver Ryan
because you can't have a license is that
true or no
is that true I don't know
it's on Wikipedia you can Source it
what oh here it wet and Reckless is the
informal name given to a crime
oh wet and Reckless that sounds so fun I
want to have a wet and Reckless get wet
and wet Reckless it just sounds like a
piece it sounds like a fun time he's
like I was not convicted of DUIs it was
wet and Reckless
Girl's Gone Wild
it is typically a result of a first
offensed UI plea in California with
defendant pleads guilty
to drunk driving offense blah blah blah
blah so it's all in the semantics of
like the specific type of charge yeah
he's trying to act like I just made it
up bad enough right I mean he's in the
New York Times bro
so maybe we you know not DUI maybe just
you were driving while intoxicated I
mean that regardless of what the charge
is called yeah I mean listen I'm not I'm
not like a lawyer I don't understand
like the technicality but the facts of
the matter is that the New York Times
reported that you were arrested for
driving drunk twice the first time you
went on probation you lost your license
and you were driving illegally the
second time hit a car ran away while
drunk and that's what's reported I don't
know if you want to call that a DUI or
whatever that's what the New York Times
reported so take it up with them
and then okay Klein has most recently
paid Wikipedia editors plural editors
hordes of editors to destroy my
Wikipedia page once again a [ __ ] flat
fabrication hordes of editors
my page has been untouched for years
with neither wife care about your Wiki
who paid you page so much you weirdo
dude that's my favorite this has been my
favorite Wrinkle in the entire story is
getting into a flame war with the Forum
mods yeah by the way Ryan Kavanaugh was
banned from Wikipedia for threatening
legal action against editors well we
still don't 100 know that was him right
but it's a it's a count that claims that
it's him that is very like the account
itself said this I am Ryan right and
also he somehow knew that a third
lawsuit was going to come out against us
this week right so nobody knew we can
infer that it is I think it's a
conclusion it's a it's an educated yeah
uh conclusion but it's not verified
trace the IP or anything well we know
he's good at not making up fake names
whenever he's doing something Shady
hence
now this one is something
so anyway it has been untouched for
years and neither positive nor negative
Edition since 2008 okay 19. it's like
okay it was fair and balanced
description of my business personal life
really it was fair and balanced I
remember there was like not even a
mention of anything of all the
controversies he's been in not even a
single mention of anything
uh in the past 45 days however Klein
coordinated an attack removing almost
anything that could be seen as positive
and replacing it with the onslaught of
negative intentionally misleading and
accurate information again you're
[ __ ] lying I don't have hordes of
Wikipedia editors just like I don't have
hordes of bots visiting our website it's
just straight malicious lies and I'll
tell you what
Wikipedia has a pretty strict rule on
what you can cite and what sources are
valid and they have left up whatever
information was put there
client started a Reddit thread where he
and his followers discuss how they plan
on harming me
and gloat about what they have achieved
okay so once again he doesn't understand
how Reddit works I have not created a
thread
and discussed how to harm you okay these
are people on our community subreddit we
as you know as we described earlier have
nothing to do with whatever they [ __ ]
write and say
as a side note they probably attack us
more than anyone else in the world
they're always going after thank you
yeah if anyone should be suing our
Subway it's me yeah
participants on the thread include uh
the same people who are editing my
Wikipedia page and bragging about what
the [ __ ] you talking about
oh based on what is he saying that
same people who are editing he's saying
it's the same yeah I mean I don't know
how the [ __ ] you would know that those
same editors also happen to be editing
h3h3 and Ethan's Wikipedia page
positively why do you care if they're
adding positive [ __ ] to my Wikipedia
what are you talking about also it's
[ __ ] Wikipedia like anybody
yeah anybody can edit it but why is he
so again so that that's just another
self-report because all of a sudden all
the negative [ __ ] started showing up on
my Wikipedia and I was like hmm I wonder
who's behind this right and now all of a
sudden he's complaining about how oh
well I've been paying editors to keep my
Wikipedia page clean no
or to you know write positive things
about me no
Klein caused his followers to flood the
App Store
and give trailers app a one star rating
prior to client's malicious attack
trailer had a four-point star 4.7 star
rating through clients coordinated
actions he caused thousands of bots
again and fake accounts as well as his
followers to leave one star ratings
thankfully the app store has removed a
number of fake ratings I'm happy for you
as we're able to prove their malicious
intent and accurate posting but still
remained the attacks on a continual
basis okay so again if you've been
watching this show
you know that I've only ever encouraged
you guys to leave honest reviews
of trailer's app that's just [ __ ] and
again he's saying I'm hiring Bots and
stuff just not true
all this amounts to textbook malicious
behavior intended to harm me in triller
this leaves me with no choice but to sue
one malignant internet personality with
a large following the equivalent of an
angry child with a loaded gun can cause
disproportionate harm to anyone using
lie slander and SEO
to suffer a few if any consequences I
mean the irony of course being that he
is a an elite Hollywood [ __ ]
personality that you've wields the legal
system to silence any criticism
what has happened to me could happen to
anyone
if a disturbed individual who espouses
race okay and then he says I'm a
disturbed individual who espouses racist
homophobic and other offensive views
again how is that relevant to your
how's that relevant
to the article
uh can muster a large obedient social
media following and attacks hopefully
this case would only stop Klein but
serve as a deterrent for others who use
social media to harm those who do not
deserve it and help set a precedent that
is this type of behavior cannot be
tolerated so there you have it the
biggest lie of course that Kavanaugh
tells in this whole article comes at the
footnotes Ryan Cavanaugh is the 26th
highest grossing movie producer of all
time
um first of all who's counting and
second of all you should probably
mention that you utterly bankrupted your
[ __ ] production company dude
Pam is coming with the receipts
oh according to the numbers.com
Kavanaugh is number two
227. wait what yeah
[Music]
227. so okay
because it's such an arbitrary number
for him to put like maybe it's a
different way of calculating it well he
doesn't Source it he doesn't say
according to what like according to what
me me yeah I was insane
yeah
how by the way how did all those hit
movies do for you bankruptcy bro
so
that's awesome you know he's not on the
Hollywood reporters list is he here's
another one from Wikipedia okay this
that's the site oh he used this citation
on Wikipedia so does it say he's
whatever 27.
let's see
it's only a top ten
it doesn't even have it it doesn't even
go cam saying that the site that we just
checked out oh it uses Wikipedia
that is the citation on Wikipedia
that's what yeah okay okay I have no
idea where he's pulling that figure from
I found something on Pinterest
I can share oh that sounds good please
do yeah let's see it looks like just
something he made and put on Pinterest
it's kind of well why stop at 21. let's
just say the you know five Ryan
Kavanaugh 21 highest gross movie
producer did we just find Ryan
Kavanaugh's Pinterest account it says
Ryan Kavanaugh
yeah we did it's all just [ __ ] of
himself wait we did just find well I
mean uh you know
we don't know that it's him but well who
else is [ __ ] doing this
why would he use his own name oh that's
right he always does that's right yeah
wow this is pretty weird this is like a
scrapbook that you would make about like
your mom would make for you what the
[ __ ] oh my God all of his wedding photos
are on his Pinterest page dude what the
hell bruh
look at this guy huh what a what a guy
the life and success in film world man
he really missed those days
I mean let's just remember you utterly
bankrupted your [ __ ] production
company
I mean we don't know that this is his
account but who the [ __ ] else is this
obsessed with Ryan Kavanaugh let's be
honest like wait well if we can find
pictures that like no one else would
have access to it could help well there
was there is a wedding photo oh I
scrolled past he even put one about him
his the homie but I'm not gonna show
that because I don't want people to dox
him but like why is that there bro
[Music]
this is very weird wow this is like a
shrine to himself
there's a folder called famous film
producer Ryan Kavanaugh
so somebody manually added all these huh
I mean is this this isn't like
automatically generated that's what I'm
wondering because I don't use Pinterest
so I I don't know but yeah maybe it's
just I mean this is an account with one
follower
right at Ryan cavanaugh05. entertainment
industry is full of opportunities around
Kavanaugh is one of them who grabbed the
chance in game name and Fame by his
enormous works
[Music]
my enormous Works what the hell are you
talking about bro
one follower one following who's the
follower let me look
her name is Hannah field
I think this might be like an
SEO thing that that someone has done
who's Hannah field
do you want me to look into it yeah I'm
curious it could just be some associate
of his
without giving away too much information
if there's not related but
yeah let's go into the Matrix on this
one
it also saved by user and it's like
tagged I mean it could be automated
still even then but I don't I don't know
it's weird regardless
I really feel like this is us SEO well
here's a PDF they attached a PDF
Frank kavan intelligent producer in
Hollywood's world
yeah so his whole shtick by the way was
that he invented an algorithm that could
tell which movie would be a hit and uh
well he's bankrupt he bankrupted the
company to be fair to be fair his
relativity media was very successful for
many years well I think that just goes
to show like his algorithm of predicting
what movies would be a hit probably was
pretty good
um it's just everything that
came afterwards like how they ran the
company clearly was not very smart
because
I mean the the company had tons of hit
movies well I think what happened is
that well whatever I'm not going to get
into the whole death of Relativity media
rhythms going the other Studio since
relativity uh relativity's downfall to
go bankrupt was
people saying Hannah is in the chat see
I think that that's that's what I was
thinking I didn't want to say but I
think that was a fan that immediately
just went to the Pinterest and followed
it I don't think there's anything oh
[ __ ] okay well the only account that he
follows is quotes inspirational and
motivational and love quotes love that
he posts that [ __ ] on his Instagram
oh my God so he's a frequency wait what
wait what does he post on his Instagram
he always posts these like [ __ ]
inspirational yeah
[Laughter]
you can match okay now we can do if you
can match your vote he's posted to that
Blog then ladies and gentlemen we got
him all right give me a minute yeah
it's all happening live
you know what we um
before we go thank our sponsors we have
to thank our sponsors all right so after
that I'm gonna read the he wrote himself
a bio on
csq quarterly
that I want to read
but there's a lot more actually to get
to so
stay with us I'm going to thank we have
two sponsors I need to thank really fast
first I want to thank hello fresh
we love hellofresh here on the podcast
the fuper Troopers love it
it's so much fun pre-portioned
ingredients fresh seasonal delivered
right to your doorstep skip the grocery
stores and count on hellofresh to make
home cooking easy fun and affordable
that's why it's number one's meal kit a
b of course famously made this burrito
doesn't that look good
amazing
um no but do you have actually real
photos Dan yeah of course sorry Amy
that's always just stays funny I have to
keep it going yeah there's some stuff
though yeah these are Super Troopers who
have sent in damn that looks so good the
reason I like hella fresh is because
one first of all if you don't know how
to cook this is a great way to learn
You're Gonna Make Beautiful delicious
home-cooked meals it's more affordable
than going out and it's even more
affordable than going to the grocery
store because
you don't have to buy a trillion you
know carrots just to use one carrot in
your recipe
um the holidays can be hectic but
hellofresh helps keep things simple with
recipes that cut back on meal prep and
clean up so you can spend less time in
the kitchen more quality time with the
friends and family hellofresh offers 50
menu and Market items to choose from
every week including vegetarian calorie
smart and Gourmet options providing
plenty of variety
um I love it
the pooper Troopers love it it's a hit
man it really is go to hellofresh.com H3
14 and use code h314 for up to 14 free
meals and three free gifts
that is hellofresh.com h314 use code
h314 for 14 free meals uh you know what
there's a reason hellofresh is America's
number one meal kit we love them and
thank you to them
and finally we've got expressvpn to
thank
expressvp and using the internet without
expressvpn is like leaving your keys in
your car while you run in the gas
station for a quick snack you know most
of the time you're probably fine
but one of these times you're going to
come back and you're going to see
someone driving off with your car it's
not worth it you need to protect
yourself every time you connect to an
uncrypted Network Cafe Hotel airports
any hacker on the same network can gain
access to your personal data passwords
Financial details doesn't take much
technical knowledge to hack someone
either just some cheap Hardware is
needed and you know a smart 14 year old
could do it and your data is very
valuable hackers can make up to a
thousand dollars per person selling
personal info on the dark web
why should you use expressvn it creates
an encryption tunnel that secures
encrypts between devices your device and
the internet so hackers cannot steal
your sensitive data it's super secure
what was that
that was not me just happened to happen
as soon as I sat here those upstairs I
don't know oh sounded like it was from
there I'm like that's not even a joined
wall
um
hackers cannot get your data that's the
point it takes hackers it's super secure
take a hacker with a super compute over
a billion years to get past expressvpn's
encryption it's easy to use it fires up
and with one click of the button you're
protected and it works on all devices
phones laptops tablets and more you can
stay secure on the go
yeah I love expressvpn it's also great
if you want to access
um
like content in another region if you
connect like Netflix and Japan or Canada
or England you're going to find all
kinds of new content to watch
fantastic for that reason I love
expressvpn because it gives me the
reassurance that my private and
sensitive data is protected so secure
your online data today by visiting
expressvpn.com H3 that's exp r e s s
vpn.com H3 and you can get an extra
three months for free that's
expressvpn.com H3 thank you thank you
all right I'm gonna grab me a water I'm
all out
parched and maybe a sodi too right
thank you all right so moving on
I got a kick out of this Ryan Kavanaugh
wrote his own I'm assuming he wrote his
own bio obviously
well you tell me who you think wrote
this I'm going to read this now
Ryan Cavanaugh is the 26th highest
grossing movie producer of all time
Source needed
the citation needed
and the co-founder of triller
one of three fastest growing social
media apps that can't be true anymore
can it
Ryan started the fight
thank you
Ryan started the fight club which
launched with record-breaking Tyson Roy
Jones event with which had the highest
grossing Pay-Per-View event
that's impressive you know
um Ryan is the founder of the financial
model that revolutionized how Hollywood
financed movies
hmm
his business model
a modified version of the Monte Carlo
method
is designed to predict the odds of Any
Given film being a financial success I'm
just saying he bankrupted his company so
I don't think that algorithm was very
successful
if it was so successful he'd be working
at relativity right now
this method was swiftly adopted by
Hollywood and radically changed the face
of media and how movies were produced
also he claims to be the this one gets a
little while the architect of Marvel
Studios
isn't that a like
that's a wild claim isn't it
it says that he says as the architect of
Marvel Studios he established the Marvel
Cinematic Universe isn't that like a
famous person Kevin feige which is
number one on that list yo how is he
claiming how is he claiming that
actually you know what I'm the architect
of Marvel Studios
relativity may have been involved early
on when they were like the original Iron
Man but how can he say he okay so let's
okay
he's the architect of Marvel Studios
there's these incredible claims one
after the other
um as you're sourcing that Dan
there's another huge claim he says Ryan
was instrumental in creating Netflix
streaming
and subscription video on demand through
a first of its kind deal with Netflix in
2010. so he's
no we got to source that claim he was
instrumental in creating Netflix
streaming
you guys got a lot to fact check back
there a lot to chew on
you know
Ryan cap so here we go Ryan Kavanaugh
founder relative media
um in the first year
he would go on to help Marvel Studios
execute one of the most iconic deals at
the time
which went end up in them creating
Marvel Cinematic Universe it was a seven
year deal that resulted in funding that
was north of 500 million it's crazy he
still bankrupted the company after all
that success so what is this the first
time see the thing is in the Marvel
Universe all these articles seem like
they're written by the same person even
the flow of things the next paragraph is
about Netflix
and it's no New York Times
yeah where did you pull that Source from
e-c-o-n-o times Econo times
interesting
sounds like propaganda
it sounds like the same altar
allegedly allegedly
in addition to his work with the film
industry Ryan is a noted philanthropist
and volunteer he's been recognized by
Cedar Sinai
and the Anti-Defamation League
among others he also rescues homeless
dogs you guys
and he helps children with major medical
conditions
and he also spends his time on
Thanksgiving
I'm not even going to say it
Ryan spearheaded the film and television
program
he did over 17 billion in worldwide bro
you're bankrupted it what the [ __ ] does
any of this matter you bankrupt the
company
I mean here's one from the LA Times
actually that talks about his
accomplishments if you want to see it at
least God damn it it's I mean I get to
the L.A times and everyone wants you to
pay you know but like ah it's so hard
when you just want to read an article
well what did you want me to read from
this because I can't open it here I can
send you the exact quotes right here
there you go yeah LA Times uh reported
that Weinstein's downfall is the most
significant Hollywood studio bankruptcy
since Ryan Kavanaugh's relativity media
filed in July 2015 so I think that's
your legacy more than anything
turns out we weren't the ones to compare
them originally yeah there's exactly L.A
times made that comparison
um so anyway let's see
um
what'd you find out way all right Dan's
on the side okay come on I think I
finally got to the bottom
of what he's trying to say with the the
MCU [ __ ] mm-hmm this is so funny because
we were just talking about this
yesterday at the office okay put it on
screen if you creativity media
uh produced
co-produced
the 2007 Nicholas cable Ghost Rider oh
my God that can not be what he's
referring which is let's be clear not
part of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and though it should be the Marvel
Universe though it should be
but
yeah this seems to be the only
connection I can find so he co-produced
a Ghostwriter movie which is a Marvel
character evidently you can't be [ __ ]
in 2007 Iron Man came out in 2008 right
and is like the first movie in the in
the actual MCU so to say that
he um helped launch the MCU this was a
poorly reviewed film right dude this is
one of
so is it is that just can I just show
you from it real quick do you find it
interesting that the one film apparently
that he was involved in is probably by
far the worst like worship algorithm on
this one dude can I give you some
comparison Ethan even I don't like this
movie 26 brutal 26 on Rotten Tomato
that's his crown jewel he established
the MCU apparently this is the only
evidence we can find to support that
there's a hunger for this character
uh we gotta revive dude you really are
Thor Thor 2 is oftenly referred to as
the worst Marvel movie and it's at 66 so
this one is like well well they forget
this one even they're like we don't even
remember right well technically not even
part of MCU like Dan said so it's wait
wait a second isn't isn't Ryan Kavanaugh
ghost riding right now
he's all flamey oh okay
okay good reference boom just I'll
applaud myself so as far as we can tell
as far as we've been able to tell that's
the only Marvel movie that Ryan's been
involved in
uh because if you go to as far as I can
tell yes I was searching around for a
while and wasn't really finding anything
this is on the Marvel Wiki
and there's a page for relativity media
his Film Production Company
co-produced Ghost Writer whatever the
[ __ ] loser did he produce a second
one because that one got 18 no it just
says Ghost Rider
dude this man is trying to claim he
created the entire Marvel Universe
because he made Ghost Rider
well if you go to Ryan Cavanaugh's IMDb
page you can see all the stuff you
produce like go back to that year and
see what's there so I want to make sure
we get this right because if we can
actually
definitively say that this is the only
film he produced for Marvel then this is
the biggest L I think of all time
yeah I created Marvel no I created
Marvel
I bought a ticket and watched Iron Man
that makes me as much responsible for
the MCU as you
he's not even listed as a producer on
Ghost Rider H3 Y is he's credited on the
H3 podcast
is this what he sent me
one credit has self
my bots my paid bot armies out of
control I never sanctioned this
joke by the way no Bots are being paid
thank you it's kind of Awesome
so apparently his only credit
oh that's his only credit since 2008 Cam
said
18. yeah thank you 18.
man
that's embarrassing bro
Ghost Rider
well I've got a bunch of memes here
oh Olivia another update you found a
Pinterest cross post I did so do you
want to you want to present to us sure
so
the website that this account that he
follows comes from is called
therandomvibes.com and so I looked up
this quote
that he posted on his Instagram
okay so we're trying so this account
that we suspect is Ryan on Pinterest
follows one account
the random Vibes right
it's from the same website
it it it pins photos from yes wait it's
on this straight up screenshotted it
yeah that's why people that's literally
what people do he took a shitty red
screenshot and may I remember okay so so
if you
this is that's him he's scrapbooking his
own [ __ ] oh absolutely okay now that we
have like pretty good evidence
connecting put that back then
the head of a major Cutting Edge New
Media platform has reposted in glorious
140p you couldn't even probably
post a [ __ ] screenshot
I mean what the hell bro
at least he cropped it before he
reposted it
how did he make it so low res when he
reposted like how do you do that
I'm not even sure how you do that same
thing as the YouTube video mm-hmm
oh right the 144p YouTube video
all right you want to pull that up just
to show the people
co-founder of triller
which one was it
this is all of his videos oh it's
possible he maybe removed and
responsible wait he still has the
triller Triad thing on his personal
uh yeah they're being sued for stealing
the tryout from someone
oops sounds pretty bad anyway let's move
on
um so Kavanaugh cav-cavs on Twitter
liking thirst trap posts of Noah back
pretty weird
Noah back's like a young man
I don't know why he's liking their
straps and Noah back to you
inappropriate
don't you think it's so awkward well
Noah Beck is uh was involved in triller
yeah and so yeah capacity
but this is just some weird girl who's
like oh no and glasses they're strapping
for him and he's like yup wait he liked
it or retweeted it no he liked it
that is a little odd
okay a little odd it's an interesting
one Cav cab who's so thirsty for Daddy
Dana White's approval by the way this
account
who I have to say I don't know who the
[ __ ] is running it I have no association
with this account before you try to
accuse me of anything Ryan Ryan or
Harvey is the name of it and he's this
guy doesn't miss man look at this meme
he posted
yes so Ryan posted this on his Instagram
trying to get the attention of Dana
White
trailer Fight Club and triad combat
kindly request your presence
dear Dana White since Fight Club has
broken every UFC viewership record I
thought perhaps you would want to see a
proper production in action
we would be more than happy to arrange a
tour so he's trying to you know
go fund Dana White who basically he's a
fly compared to him but
this idiot calls me every day text me
every day please answer my call please
talk to me why won't you talk just to be
clear
this is actually Dana White talking
about Ryan Kavanaugh somebody asked him
about him at a press conference yeah and
this is literally him talking about Ryan
it calls me every day text me every day
please answer my call please talk to me
why won't you talk to me
because I don't give a [ __ ] about you
oh my God don't even ask me about these
idiots who gives a [ __ ]
I don't give a [ __ ] what they think
you think I care what triller thinks
what are you doing I don't even know
what you're doing what is this trailer
reportedly sued by data 500 fronted byp
extreme for allegedly uh for alleged
Trigon ring rip-off thing you're trying
to build what are you doing
you know and and and why are you talking
about what lawsuit I have to do with it
what do I have to do with it or on my
guys do your thing
what are you doing go [ __ ] go away
stop texting me stop calling me and stop
[ __ ] asking immediate everybody
thanks okay beat it get lost I wish Dana
White or one of these other people from
his previous lives would like reach out
and pay for my lawsuit or something so
that people that hate him in the world
it's like wish someone would back me the
[ __ ] up I don't know why I have to fight
this fight by myself man like damn
I smoke marijuana so I don't beat my
wife and children right that's Dana
White but
still love him
he was quoting somebody yeah he was
quoting somebody else but you know what
I mean I feel like the last Dana's doing
this no I love Dana the last don't say
you love Dana either let's just we're
neutral on Dan
uh hey just help me pave Brian Captain
okay I got it okay in that case the last
time I got in a legal battle with Matt
Haas I feel like the whole internet
supported me and it was like a really
beautiful thing now I feel like even
More's on the line and I just feel like
I'm fighting this thing by myself and it
sucks yeah I mean you were a much
smaller Creator then and you know people
I think there was more of an underdog
Dynamic although that Dynamic is still
here because Ryan Kavanaugh is still
like a billionaire according to well
according whatever article he's written
yeah exactly
but well he just employed like the bit
the most famous definition lawyer in the
country yeah
how big my hands look
whoa
normal sized cam by the way
actually this is a super large one they
started making like 20 ounces and the
chat is uh reminding you that uh
that you do have a lot of people
supporting oh that's thank that's true
the fupa Troopers have my back and it's
especially when the third lawsuit was
posted it's really nice to see the
amount of support we've been getting
that it means so much it's so nice to
see and that people are invested in the
stupid little story that like some
random nobody you know it's hard to get
invested in this stuff but I'm really
glad to see people care I think I'm
mostly talking about media outlets and
creators and stuff like that yeah yeah
it'd be nice to see you know somebody
[ __ ] rallied around this case it is
so important and I get that they're
probably you know afraid to get involved
Matt Haas was a nobody and Ryan
Kavanaugh has a habit of suing and going
after anyone that says anything about it
so true yeah but like damn it just it's
it's just it feels bad to be I mean it's
just it's scary and it feels bad to be
fighting it by myself in that regard but
all your guys's support especially
around this third one is just huge huge
huge it thank you guys so much it really
does
make me feel supported so thank you guys
the chat wants to know that you don't
have fans you have family
family family family family family
family family family family family
family family family family
thank you guys yeah I love all y'all
thank you so much
and thank you for caring about this you
know it's hard to care about someone
else's problems when it doesn't even
like directly affect you you know
but it does affect us family family
family family
this one is more impactful than the
first one by a lot I'm just telling you
to any Creator oh yeah Philly D so The
Hollywood Reporter reporter and Philly D
asked me for comment which I thought was
good did anyone watch Philly D's
coverage of it yet apparently it just
dropped the chat was just saying I gave
him a really
I gave him a really long time
and detailed statement and I asked him
to please read it in full so I'm curious
if he did
I it must have just dropped because on
his oh there it is oh yeah you're in the
thumbnail
another one
let's go
so I was happy to see Philly covering it
I was like all right and Hollywood
Reporter so we spent uh I'm looking at
it and according to timestamps 10
minutes of the uh 17 minute video is
spent on the story so
well let's watch and see
um but okay so we're getting to well
actually I want to watch let's watch it
out at the end here because I have more
to talk about
um here basically The Hollywood Reporter
posted an article about this third
lawsuit and I'm like finally one of
these guys is reporting on this [ __ ]
um Ryan Cavanaugh's new Mindbender when
a lawsuit is not a lawsuit
and they're talking about this weird
technicality where he's like well it was
never filed so it's defamation about the
Ponzi one mm-hmm
a defamation case from the controversial
entertainment veteran figures to explore
a secret about the court system that
hardly anyone knows about
so they go on to say uh
basically that there was a lawsuit
by some media organization that
pressured
the legal system that they need to make
lawsuits available to the Press
immediately
and so it created this weird
dynamic where the Press gets the
lawsuits before the actual attorneys do
uh let's turn to a defamation law quote
lawsuit
love that
quote filed
by Ryan Cavanaugh against the podcaster
Ethan Klein this is a No Ordinary case
and lawyers reporters other would be
wise to pay attention as it's headed
towards exploring the quantum state of
litigation
before getting to what Kavanaugh alleges
it's necessary to introduce this
controversial entertainment industry
veteran as well as discuss a quirk
of the jury Prudence of Los Angeles so
hardly anyone knows about
Kavanaugh 2004 made a splash by founding
an indie Studio relativity media that
has supposedly cracked the tough
business of movie making meaning he had
a quantitative approach towards
production perhaps partly due to the
success at the time of the movie
moneyballed Kavanaugh's method attracted
interest
and the man had a lot of connections too
future U.S treasury secretary Steve
mnuchin good guy by the way good
reputation
was an investor and for a brief period
he was also relativity's co-chairman you
know what's so interesting about that is
that he that gives him a direct tie into
the Trump Administration and there has
been these conspiracies that he bought
triller
knowing that Trump was about to ban
Tick-Tock that it was some weird but
this is all allegations obviously and
and uh
speculation
was an investor for a brief the company
burned through hundreds of millions of
dollars before one of the most notorious
Hollywood bankruptcies ever so there you
go that's your legacy bro
Kavanaugh feuding with investors wound
up on the cover of The Hollywood
Reporter well let's see what the cover
was
relativities Ryan
I'm sorry
exclusive Ryan Kavanaugh breaks silence
points fingers and emotional
post-bankruptcy interview
alrighty
since relativity's bankruptcy Kavanaugh
has been involved in all sorts of
projects as well as legal entanglements
2017 he launched a new company Proxima
media
along with this dude Elon Sparr
the Endeavor however got off to an
unuspicious start when Kavanaugh Spar
started pointing fingers at each other
over funding and secrets Spar even
accused Kavanaugh of operating a Ponzi
scheme
which variety picked up for a headline
in its own story this will become
relevant later more on what happened in
a bit but just know that Kavanaugh and
Spar were able to find some sort of
Revel uh resolution
Kavanaugh's proxim Proxima then acquired
a majority interest in triller social
media site that among other things has
distributed Pay-Per-View boxing matches
when people started pirating those Feist
trailer filed many copyright suits one
of the targets was Ethan Klein whose H3
pocket used a clip of the Jake Paul
fight you see someone who actually
[ __ ] like just that simple reporting
H3 used a clip
thank you when you read Ryan's press
release Ethan pirated the Sun the whole
thing and caused hundreds of millions in
Damages yeah I used a clip
this has led to yet another fuel Feud
for Kavanaugh one that has escalated
over several months Klein has attacked
Kavanaugh versus
mercilessly on his podcast for example
just before Thanksgiving
he posted an episode title Ryan
Kavanaugh's Wikipedia is a battlefield
in response Kavanaugh filed more legal
grenades for a tortoise interference
lawsuit Kavanaugh is now being
represented by Thomas Claire one of the
country's most famous reputation lawyers
there you have it
Kavanaugh's latest complaint against
Klein Flags the podcast for repeatedly
and relentlessly attacking and
continuing attack Mr Kavanaugh in a
variety of ways but specifically by
republishing the defamatory and highly
damaging accusations which they knew to
be false
that Mr Kavanaugh was accused of running
a Ponzi scheme I don't know that to be
false I only know that like again to
this day it's like
I'm just reading the headline
I know you guys resolved behind the
scenes which I've stated
I only know what your previous partner
said of you
um
what's weird in meta is that he wrote
this article the day the FI the
complaint was filed and I didn't have
the lawsuit yet but he was quoting from
the complaint
which I think was intentional by the
author
to do like this weird meta-analysis
right later Klein began selling T-shirts
to fans with the slogan govern yourself
accordingly
which depicts Mr Kavanaugh and a
criminal defendant in a courtroom
doubling down
on Klein's defamatory suggestion that
again I'm not I'm not suggesting any it
says defamatorization Mr Clan ran a
criminal Enterprise that's a quote from
his thing but
uh I'm not implying that he ran a
criminal Enterprise
of course not when it comes to
defamation law
blah blah blah
anyway they going to talk about how Spar
two years later Spar submitted a
complaint to the Los Angeles Superior
Court against Ryan Kavanaugh and
Kavanaugh submitted his own against Spar
a very way weird thing to happen within
hours Kavanaugh's rep was calling media
outlets and insisting that no lawsuit
had actually been filed and that news
stories on the matter were defamatory do
you see what a weird litigious piece of
[ __ ] this guy is he files a lawsuit and
then his rep starts calling media
Outlets insisting no lawsuit had
actually been filed and that reports on
it are defamatory and the author says I
know because I was the recipient of one
of these phone calls
Kavanaugh even put out a statement at
the time accusing Variety in The
Hollywood Reporter of having attempted
to smear him by quoting from pars
spars seeming legal filings
you know
so then he goes on to explain how that
happened
and how it's super bizarre and that's
about it I'm glad he's talking about it
though but I it just shows how what a
petty [ __ ] weirdo he is that he files
a lawsuit and then immediately starts it
starts having his rep threatening news
organizations to not talk about it or
get sued
yeah
um
someone on the subreddit made a really
great point about it I thought was good
uh Kavanaugh PSA Kavanaugh is an elitist
piece of [ __ ] I know we're all here for
Goofs and gas and I love the way Ethan's
approached the situation in terms of
poking fun at it but I'm getting
increasingly angry I feel Ryan is the
perfect example of a Hollywood Elite
doing essentially anything they want and
coming out on top I feel he started this
lawsuit without knowing the previous
legal battles that H3 has gone through
and is now
trying to take Ethan and Ela for
everything they have because he's been
challenged it starts with Monica uh
it started with monetary gain but is now
a pathetic attempt at saving his
fractured ego his recent instant post
bragging about suing uh about suing
others
he's bragging about suing me
[ __ ] you you entitled prick I'm glad
Ethan his team seemed to be standing
their ground calling out this nonsense
and challenging a man who has likely
gotten away with stunts like this time
and time again over the years
exactly you know
it's like this dude is used to
threatening doing whatever he wants
without any recourse and the only
difference this time is that I'm
standing my ground and I'm refusing to
get bullied and it's driving him crazy
and so he's not backing down three
lawsuits now three lawsuits
I have done nothing
I'm not suing anybody I'm just defending
myself and standing up for what's right
and talking some [ __ ] along the way but
there's nothing illegal about that I'm
not bro I'm literally just reading
headlines that other people wrote
and the [ __ ] talking wouldn't happen if
you weren't being sued yeah I mean just
a response I'm not saying that this is a
bad thing
so we talk some [ __ ] on the show I'm not
talking [ __ ] about you were you were
defending you're right as an American
yeah I'm not talking [ __ ]
I'm literally reading headlines of
articles that are reposed by other
people and defending my right
to fair use and Free Speech
if you want to call that [ __ ] talking
then by all means
we don't talk [ __ ] we eat poop camp said
Ryan Kavanaugh just eat I got famous
eating poop whatever that is
[ __ ] my face
then Ryan Cavanaugh the quartering
suing me I'm not taking a pause to [ __ ]
all over the floor
um by the way I don't know if this
screenshot's real or not and by the way
I do want to preface this by saying do
not harass do not send them DMs I don't
condone this in fact
well I'm only showing this to show how
desperate Ryan is for I guess dirt on me
but
hi Ryan Ethan Klein recently tried to
bribe people on his Discord to go to
your social media accounts and lie about
you would you like a screenshot of the
message
sure not sure if this real or fake but
sure so okay
baited
don't do this guys I just want to say
that I don't condone uh doing this
um
there's been a lot of content coming out
recently oh yeah Ryan Cavanaugh put a
Ethan Klein section on his Instagram
apparently
oh if you guys want to read by the way
and it's ahead of anything else enter
the Triad
a Snoop Dogg Metallica these are all big
things for his company no number one
Ethan Klein
love that
love that for him
yes so basically
at this point
I prepared this huge statement for
Philly D
and let's see if he actually read it
this was a really funny one me when I
read on capcom's article that Ethan is
paying people to go to uh
does Ryan Kavanaugh look like Harvey
weinstein.com yeah knowing I've been
searching Ryan's name and spending time
on the site every single day without
compensation you guys are getting paid
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
so fun
by the way let's check in on that let's
open an incognito tab
and type Ryan Kavanaugh
I mean Google is obviously doing a value
assessment on the website
and let's see well his article is doing
well so his see his articles is rating
above ours
our website
interesting I wonder how that happened
yeah but I'm gonna click this spend some
time on it
I'll just leave it open and say
and I uh watch Philly cheese
great choice yeah so let's see Philly D
okay this is so this is good you know
this is I'm gonna like it
this is good this is good too
oh this wait I'm locked in as you bro
you subscribed
hmm
don't put don't throw me under the bus
no I'm just saying subscribe like And
subscribe
damn be like you don't even subscribe
I'm logged in it wasn't on accusation
that's my account
by the way what is that clothes I'm
wearing it looks good it's heavy fresh
steady fresh can you get that at
teddyfresh.com also I like this image
you used to Brian
it looks like he has soy eye
I look good as hell and he looks like
soy eyed
looks like he's gone through some [ __ ]
damn fourth lawsuit incoming
I have a soy allergy I've never consumed
soy I'm not a soy boy
I don't appreciate your implication
okay well at any rate I'm just huge I
haven't washed it yet but I'm just very
happy to see Philly the mainstream
coverage of this finally you know it's
come long enough so the new H3
defamation lawsuit is bigger than most
realize okay let's watch is it time
stamped wow it's right at the beginning
he didn't hit us with the sub where's
the sub did he drop this up he opened
with a wow I guess that means serious
all right well I'm excited to watch this
so
thank you thank you a crazy one for you
but before we jump into it I just want
to say today is my birthday too oh my
God
happy birthday happy for what versions
cam made this by the way and it [ __ ]
killed me yesterday
future thumbnail
for sure
by the way straight up he's like I don't
look like that they post photoshopped
images of me to defame me
[Laughter]
what do you mean you don't look like
that
we made the edit so we could easily tell
you apart from Harvey
that's so fine bro I love that image so
much
POV Ryan Kavanaugh's Whiskey Bottle on
Thanksgiving
laughs
oh brutal all right let's watch Philly
at the like comment especially if you've
never left a comment on this video
before and maybe even share Today's Show
especially because uh numbers 50
000 concurrent viewers right now I'm
sharing this for you Philly let's go
there's actually could have huge
consequences both nationally and
internationally but yeah with that said
welcome back to the Philip DeFranco Show
You Beautiful Bastard and let's just
jump into it you know the first thing
that we have to talk about today is this
massive news around Ethan Klein AKA H3
Productions AKA a guy who just seems to
be a lightning rod for lawsuits by the
way Philly looks super skinny doesn't he
looks like really good Legends
it looks really good
love that man
love how skinny he is I don't know who
Ethan Klein is you love him you hate him
it doesn't even matter because the story
is bigger than just one man there's a
story and a lawsuit that's about piracy
versus fair use it's about defamation
versus reporting that legal limitations
of what you can report when a lawsuit is
not a lawsuit so just like Ethan Klein's
last fair use lawsuit this could be
precedent seven so with that said as far
as who's on okay
thank you finally somebody is like
looking at this the right way I mean
thank you Philly he had my back last
time or not not like in a bite like he
understood the gravity of the lawsuit
last time and it looks like he's
understanding the gravity of it this
time we love a skinny Legend
other end of this lawsuit you have Ryan
Kavanaugh who if you don't know is a
film producer and businessman as well is
a co-founder majority holder and trailer
and yesterday he filed a lawsuit against
Ethan though things actually started
with a legal spat we covered in the past
for that being when triller initially
sued Ethan in H3 for airing a portion of
its Jake Paul versus Ben Aspen fight
during one of its podcasts earlier this
year Hillary filed a massive lawsuit
against several entities that had
accused of pirating the fight at that
time but a court dismissed the majority
of the defendants though it did allow
for trailer to refile against Outlets
individually what happened just to be
specific is that they threw everything
like a billion people in one lawsuit and
the judge was like this is the dumbest
[ __ ] I've ever seen it's an improper
jointer I'm throwing it out entirely the
judge was like you guys are idiots like
the judge was so [ __ ] harsh I wish we
still had that judge but we got assigned
to a different judge
um nothing wrong with our judges though
not not the not the you know say
anything bad about her she seems to be
smart and doing a good job but um
um so what happened was the judge
dropped it and then they only refiled
against us so explain that [ __ ] and that
allows you to allege copyright
infringement among other claims at that
time even hit back saying that his
inclusion of the fight should fall under
fair use which then leads us to
yesterday Ryan Kavanaugh wrote an essay
titled the dark side of the power of
social media explaining more about his
recent lawsuit and why he's saying that
he filed it there we saw Ryan repeat
claims that Ethan pirated and
broadcasted that fight to millions of
people resulting in hundreds of millions
of dollars in Lost sales for trailer
while Ethan profited also saying that
Ethan initially seemed willing to settle
but then quote against all common legal
practices rather than negotiating a good
faith he disclosed his views on the suit
and the terms of the discussed
settlement on his podcast to millions of
viewers and further disparage Thriller
Ryan going on to claim that this was a
bad faith tactic and violation of
litigation laws all of that is kind of
an explanation of the first part of the
story but then it moves from a piracy
issue to a defamation issue from there
Ryan claimed that Ethan has posted video
after video attacking and slandering me
personally despite the fact that while I
am a shareholder and co-founder I am not
triller right among other things
accusing Ethan of trying to use his
video titles to optimize search results
so that his videos show up when someone
searches the name Ryan literally just
put his name in the title but
sorry I just Ryan adding that Ethan's
father Amplified the attacks right now
so specifically alleging that despite
the faculty has never met Ethan Ethan
has posted more than eight podcasts
disparaging him with those podcasts
including pulse and harmful information
right and also according to a website
Ethan made that compares him to Harvey
Weinstein and then claimed that Ethan
sent paid traffic to push disparaging
articles to the top of Google search
results about him saying that he's
encouraged H3 fans to attack him online
and threaten his family Ryan
additionally brought up a Variety
article that Ethan has referenced in the
past with a headline that says Ryan was
accused of running a Ponzi scheme but
Ryan arguing that Ethan is bringing up
this article in bad faith because an
update in the story notes that the
situation was solved and the complaint
was never intentionally filed Ryan also
accused Ethan of making other defamatory
remarks like claims Orion is not
properly paid his employees or Nanny and
that he's gotten two DUIs which Ryan
says it's false Kavanaugh also alleging
that Ethan paid Wikipedia editors to
quote destroy his page with negative
Edition started a Reddit thread for
people to plan attacks against him and
gloat about their successes and caused
his followers and paid Bots to give the
trailer online read it with Ryan saying
all of this amounts to textbook
malicious behavior intended to harm me
and triller this leaves me with no
choice but to sue unbalignant internet
personality with a large following the
equivalent of an angry child with a
loaded gun can cause disproportionate
harm to anyone using lies slander and
SEO and suffer few if any consequences
now I understand that is a lot it's kind
of this shotgun blast of accusations
I'm glad that Philly reached out to me
for an argument because even if you're
familiar with it if you read all that
you might like even if you're partial
towards me you'd be like that sounds
like he's gone he's done too much he's
gone too far he's brought this on
himself and he's got to deal with the
consequences the truth is that
everything he's saying is totally
[ __ ] fabricated it's not what
happened so I'm I'm glad he reached out
let's see what he does with my comment
so many things and more could even be on
the way but I will link to the full
article down below as you can see every
detail as he explained it but of course
in a situation we're talking about a
lawsuit right I just explained the
accusations from one side what does the
other side think so with that it reached
out to Ethan Klein for a comment or
response regarding the accusations or
any of this in general and he gave a
lengthy response of even starting off by
saying Ryan Cavanaugh's first malicious
lie is that he claims I pirated his
event fair use is at the heart of this
awesome images
it's pretty awesome I'm talking about
legal stuff yeah of course I'm right I'm
the judge and the jury my wife's the
bailiff let's go
this is at the heart of this lawsuit
same as with our first lawsuit
my statement that I crafted Ryan
Kavanaugh's first malicious lie is that
he claims I pirated his event fair use
is at the heart of this lawsuit same as
with our first lawsuit used a short clip
of the event during an extremely
critical commentary during a three-hour
podcast Ryan Cavanaugh tries to blame me
for his event being widely pirated which
is pure defamation he didn't even react
to the event until days after it was
streamed on pay-per-view if he cared
about Pirates why did he drop all of his
other lawsuits against actual Pirates
but only kept the one against me even
going on to accuse Ryan of targeted
illegal harassment asking why his wife's
Teddy Fresh brand is listed in the suit
when he says it has nothing to do with
the case at hand Ethan also denying that
he told his fans to harass Ryan online
claiming that he's actually done the
opposite on multiple occasions then he
brought up a series of articles that
addressed some of the specific
accusations Ryan made including the
variety situation we mentioned even
claiming that he made it clear that the
accusation was retracted adding that if
Ryan quote has a problem with the
article take it up with variety one of
the most trusted news sources in
entertainment not me even then
addressing Ryan's claims that he was
spreading both information regarding
DUIs and paying employees but even
arguing that he was just referencing
information made available in articles
by well-regarded news sources pointing
to three New York Times articles from
2008 that say that Ryan was charged for
drunk driving in 2006 and was arrested
for the same thing again in 2008 also
sharing a Vanity Fair article that
brings up the same arrests regarding the
accusation about Ryan not paying his
Nanny Ethan pointed to an article from
Fox San Diego that says Orion's former
Nanny sued him for 175 000 and lost
wages after she was abruptly fired in
2020. that reportedly just two months
into a contract that was meant to last
over a year with Ethan writing again I
am not creating any of these claims but
merely reading what has already been
published by well-respected news sources
how is that defamation regarding the
accusations that Ethan sent Bots to give
Thriller negative reviews Ethan said
that Ryan is solely blaming him when
other big influencers have been critical
of the app as well including Noah Beck a
trailer advisor and shareholder who made
a tick tock complaining about how
trailer's camera is flipped but even
claiming that he's only told his fans to
give honest and genuine reviews Ethan
also going on to share a Hollywood
Reporter article where an investor
reportedly told a judge in a town full
of scam artists posers false prophets
and flim-flam men Ryan C cabin is in a
Hollywood Class by Himself even also
linking to articles from variety and
deadline that say a judge found Ryan and
fabricated a memo which included false
sexual harassment claims against an
executive at his previous production
company but even closing his statement
To Us by saying Ryan Kavanaugh is a
business Elite who is used to suing
harassing and breaking the law with no
consequences he wields the legal system
like a malignant Tyrant uses it to
silence his critics and now to stifle
fair use something we all on YouTube
should care about we've been also
addressing the entire situation with
Ryan on Twitter writing Ryan Kavanaugh
is trying to get my channel banned from
YouTube a powerful media person who has
gone to every length to destroy me for
criticizing him everyone needs to pay
attention now not only is fair use on
the line but the powerful trying to shut
down channels for criticism with him
then pointing to a Wikipedia user who he
thinks might be Ryan saying that the
user admitted to sending legal notices
to YouTube and twitch to get h3h3 bam
and in that same Twitter thread Ethan
shared what he called a threatening
Instagram DM that Ryan allegedly sent
him which shows Ryan laying out some of
the accusations we just mentioned in
warning Ethan to stop so you have all of
that but then there's also an aspect of
the story that I feel like is getting
overlooked because obviously there's a
lot of big Asians being thrown around a
lot of drama but it was hit on really
well by Eric Gardner and The Hollywood
Reporter who explained a defamation case
from the controversial entertainment
veteran figures to explore a secret
about the court system that hardly
anyone knows about remember that Variety
article that both Ethan and Ryan have
mentioned so is Gardner and The
Hollywood Reporter explain about a
decade ago an entity called Courthouse
News service began suing local Court
officials around the nation for not
providing immediate or near immediate
online access to court filings and
adding this service experienced some
success making the argument that the
first and 14th amendment required
nothing short of transparency and as a
result the Los Angeles Superior Court
System opened a media portal for
reporters a gardener going on to explain
this is where it gets problematic noting
it takes a bit of time for court filings
to be processed lawsuits are indexed and
assigned and for the few hours it takes
for this to happen reporters get access
to what the LA Superior Court calls
quote unfiled complaints with a court
even stamping the words unfiled on every
pages of these filings the Garner then
going on to ask and answer the question
what would happen if a lawyer submitted
a complaint into the system and then
came to a quick settlement before the
complaint got indexed explaining that
that's what happened two years ago
explaining that in 2017 Kavanaugh
launched a new company Proxima media and
along with an individual named Elon
spahr he pursued a new entertainment
stock exchange but saying this then led
to Kavanaugh and Spar pointing fingers
at each other over funding and secrets
but then reporting within hours of
submitting the complaints Kavanaugh's
wrap was calling media outlets and
insisting that no lawsuit had actually
been filed in that news stories on the
matter were defamatory with Gardner
noting I know because I was the
recipient of one of those phone calls
reporting that Kavanaugh even put out a
statement at that time accusing Variety
in The Hollywood Reporter of having
quote attempted to smear him by quoting
from spars seeming legal filings but
then adding that Kavanaugh never did Sue
The Hollywood Reporter nor variety over
the story about his tussle with Spar
saying whether he was Satisfied by the
clarifications appended to the Articles
or cowered by the admonishment that fair
reporting privilege would cover these
stories he backed off and potentially
related to that situation or now Ethan
Gardner writing that when it comes to
defamation law most States including
California have a defense known as Fair
reporting privilege which basically
means that anyone is free to talk about
judicial and other governmental
proceedings without fearing liability
for repeating allegations made there the
only caveat is that the report has to be
both a fair and true account of public
proceed and noting the media relies
mightily on this privilege and they're
noting the example of how BuzzFeed beat
defamation suits over its publication of
the infamous Trump dossier so yeah like
I said at the beginning of this story a
lot of stuff at play here and depending
on how things go potentially massive
consequences but for now we're gonna
have to wait to see what happens though
I mean this is a developing story even
right before I uploaded Today's Show I
saw Ethan Klein going live addressing
this matter so we may see even more
information more updates but while we
wait to see what happens from here I do
want to pass the question off to you
what are you guys think
okay so I mean pretty good he gave my
statement of fair Shake but it's like
foreign
it's like okay who cares about the the
technicality of if it was filed or not I
have nothing to do with the variety
Oracle that was written
if you don't like the article tell
variety to take it down I can read a
[ __ ] headline
um anyway I wish I I I get it but I wish
that uh I'd like to see a stronger
stance from Philly but it's his birthday
and we love him and he looks skinny and
healthy and we love that for him hey
skinny Legend skinny Legend happy
birthday too you know because at least
he's covering it you know I I'll say
that no you know what I I'm happy it was
good he's covering it I think that's
great I think as long as more people
know about it the better
because the facts and everything's on
our side I mean and it's all developing
and I mean uh you didn't even get the
actual lawsuit until right before we
went live yeah
um so yeah I mean yeah it still
dissolved but yeah I I should I
shouldn't complain I think Philly did a
great job he represented me well and um
he covered it you know which was awesome
but I do long for those days
when he was like [ __ ] Matt Haas this guy
is trying to ruin YouTube because the
same is true I understand being more
more hesitant to [ __ ] with oh yeah
nobody wants to get [ __ ] Wrath of
Kavanaugh on their ass so but okay happy
birthday Philly thanks for covering the
story we love you Legend
skinny he does look like he he looks
good though for real
it's hot let me read some of the
comments yeah rank Ryan is the
definition of petty I agree
sound like Ryan has never really
heard of this really cool thing called
the First Amendment thank you [ __ ]
exactly
shout out to GID well as my lawyer
stated and one of the responses which
was awesome was free speech for me and
not for thee he loves the first
amendment when it comes to his own
speech
thank you for reporting on the history
lawsuit it's important it's not getting
enough coverage thank you well thank you
that's nice I'm glad to see the comments
and people uh rallying and support so
thank you to Philly go actually I'll
read the uh
the statement because which I don't have
access to great
I have to give myself access give
yourself permission because I wanted to
read it in full actually he didn't even
read my favorite line
it was a long statement I don't
I was going to be surprised no I thought
it was good I thought he would like it
I think he presented the yeah I agree
I'm happy that's the best nuggets well
I'm happy I took the time to actually
Source everything because it's like look
these are all reported and I'm glad he
showed it all too he's like yeah the New
York Times reported this guy was drunk
driving
so
oh [ __ ] I don't know why
I shared it with your email
share
it's not
let me try again
why is it not working
I shared it with you
it's actually shared with everybody wait
oh [ __ ]
hang on guys
bear with me here
um I got it I got it I know dead air
Danny got anything but I don't even have
access to it how do I not have access to
it what dude
how do I not have access to my own damn
document that I cannot help you on you
know while we wait I could show this to
the audience no one believed that I eat
I cannot believe what's happening yeah
maybe he's chewing on a raw potato over
here what the hell like an apple
oh yeah brother the hell are you doing
why this is why I've just I've always
snacked on it since I was a kid and no
one I didn't know this was weird to like
a few months ago when you guys were like
that is the most isn't it too hard to
eat like I'm showing fine wait isn't
there something bad about eating a rope
I've read that yeah I turned out okay
with it there's something in it that's
bad I don't want to scare you though but
we'll Google that fact check that
raw potatoes are more likely to cause
digestive issues do you have digestive
issues no starch
Ron cooked potatoes can be enjoyed
moderation I'm not seeing any like
immediate red flags on it I don't know I
just feel like it'd be boring
well man that's no I like it with some
salt it's good I just didn't realize how
loud it was until every bite Olivia was
looking over at me
the potato is allowed food you got chips
you got raw potato it's a cruncher right
it's a cruncher so true actually
inherently toxic and chances are you'll
be fine consuming one there are a number
of reasons why eating an uncooked potato
isn't great for your body or your taste
buds well that's just your [ __ ]
opinion myrecipes.com
where the [ __ ] editorial article
I wrote it last night in my email
can you see what email it's owned by
maybe you shared it in the what's up
maybe we can find it that way
so weird
[Music]
like
God it just asked for Access so you
should send an email oh maybe it's the
podcast uh
maybe I was logged in as the podcast and
wrote it there here's uh some more
potato ASMR while you guys wait uh maybe
we can read those big donations oh yeah
oh that's a better idea look good
some big juicy ones Ian
McIntyre McIntyre oh McIntosh McIntyre
oh well it's just MC
not Mac anyways
uh after giving us five years of free
entertainment through the ha suit
pregnancies covid and now this it's our
privilege to help you fight this one uh
this one star harassment suit thanks
Ethan Ela and the whole Acer team for
making us laugh through hard times and
sticking up to Rich to this Rich douche
bless heart and a 200 donation thank you
1200 [ __ ] god thank you bro
thank you uh Charlie P
uth
I don't think
isn't that a famous person Charlie puth
yeah wait who's Charlie puth the singer
the one who was mean to Dax flame to Dax
yeah uh yeah he's the one that Dax
wanted to beef with yeah
is that that's not the real Charlie puth
no no no okay you mean who comments
you're like no no of course you said
this comes from Charlie puth no it's
actually come from Charlie P and I was
speculating what the last name was all
right pluth not Charlie puth all right
Charlie pluth says uh here's a hundred
dollars use this for the legal fund
please let us donate to a GoFundMe to
fight this bully I don't think that's
gonna happen after the drama and the
last time I'd love to but
I think I got killed until last year
people still thought Ethan uh took that
money and I don't think it was ever
really clear to me what they thought you
did with it they thought that I I don't
know because I clearly paid for the
lawsuit right yeah it's like I clearly
fought an expensive lawsuit to its
conclusion the whole the whole situation
never actually made sense if you spent
longer than a second thinking about it
uh Dougherty
dordy gussevski sorry sorry
uh two another 200 Zach hit the war horn
foot soldiers are going to war Zach for
200 bucks and by going to war I assume
he means just watching and enjoying the
podcast metaphorical war and not
actually doing any uh
or anything or harassing because we
don't know harassing no lying nobody we
don't do that so when you say go to war
I say watching the podcast
enthusiastically and I love that and
thank you so much for your support
that's that's the only support we need
uh what's an AED
uh when it comes to why can't I find
this article you guys are driving me
insane
I swear I should uh United Arab Emirate
uh dear durhams okay well they donated
369.99 of those which is a hundred
dollars and they just said aren't I'm RK
oh he's RK the mod yeah
oh [ __ ]
well thank you thanks for the hundred
bucks
do you have your
Sports
did you get your shots
no
no no I got it why are we doing this
watch did you get your shots girl would
you like to come back with Rob to
America hold on I have a very important
time sensitive donation America
rotten potatoes killed my entire killed
an entire family from Russia did you get
maybe that's America
of course
thank you for the
I'm immune I've been having since I was
a kid okay
did you get your shots
[Music]
how dare you interrupt me it's my fave
[Music]
I can't find the document I don't know
did you [ __ ] did you figure it out you
sent it in WhatsApp yesterday I put that
to my door I don't know if you had
revisions to a Duffy's other than the
roster but it doesn't open for you I'm
assuming can you post the link
in the WhatsApp no it's looking this way
I posted it I'm gonna Post in the bottom
of the document now let me have the dog
the doc that we've been using all day I
put in there oh so what the [ __ ] did I
link okay I got it
I got it I got it
this is the text from the WhatsApp so I
don't know if you made it oh
I see what you did yeah because I did
change it a bit actually here
I sent his
I sent a girl from Philly D the final so
I'll just post it in there
it's just the formatting was super weird
because I like posted it to Twitter DMs
[Music]
uh Jesse Nelson donated 100 and said to
war in Minecraft okay good in Minecraft
exactly
we're gonna bit we're gonna burn his
Minecraft village to the ground
how to talk to me you will be the mother
thank you so much for your support
[Applause]
the thing is like I just the thing is
about doing like a GoFundMe or something
is like I just I'm very I'm rich I mean
so it looks a little [ __ ] dumb
doesn't it
yeah a little bit yeah exactly uh
somebody donated five bucks and said cab
produced I Now Pronounce You Chuck and
Larry but is accusing Ethan of
homophobia and with the thinky face uh
hmm I haven't seen that movie is it
homophobic you could say that yeah yeah
also he's [ __ ] friends with Steve
mnuchin are you [ __ ] kidding me like
okay wait I pray I forwarded you guys
the email of the final version and then
oh boy this better be worse if you get
all the trouble we've gone through this
better be good and then if you could
paste it over the um
over this then it'll be ready I'm glad
he called out Noah Beck's criticism of
the app though Philly D that was great
so you want me to just put it in here
just paste it over this document that
that the one that love made yes
okay there you go all right great so I'm
just going to put this document up here
we go
so we're gonna have to put this
statement up on you see how the
formatting is crazy like this is a URL I
don't know why the text got like one
it's like normal and then one to one
font size all right
what the [ __ ] is that [ __ ] every time I
posted a link look at this [ __ ] for
their dog like what the [ __ ] is this
yeah it works it's just like what
happened at the bottom it gets super
scuffed let me see
it gets what huge oh yeah so this this
is what I sent them
I wish you would have formed he would
have helped me out with the formatting
fill it because I saw he just strictly
screenshotted it but I wasn't gonna
anyway here I'm gonna read it okay okay
we should put this statement up on um
does Ryan Kavanaugh look like Harvey
wants can we keep this for me
this is a serious statement
all right first frying Kavanaugh's right
Count's first malicious lie is that he
claims that pirated the event fair use
is at the heart of this lawsuit same as
with our first lawsuit we use a short
clip of the event during an extremely
critical commentary during a three-hour
podcast Ryan Cavanaugh tries to blame me
for his event being widely pirated which
is pure defamation we didn't even react
to the event until days after it was
streamed on pay-per-view if he cared
about Pirates why did he drop all of his
other lawsuits against actual buyers
only kept the one against me
but
why is he suing Teddy fresh a separate
and unrelated business entity the answer
is obviously targeted legal harassment
he claims I have encouraged my followers
to attack him on social media something
I have routinely discouraged I have on
many occasions told our audience not to
harass or engage with him on social
media
Ryan Kavanaugh claims that I have
propped up a defamatory article that is
debunked in the title that is a lie here
I link to the
I think this is the the Ponzi
yeah article
I said where is it debunked in the title
his partner retracted the statement
which we have made it clear many times
on the podcast if he has a problem with
the article taken up with variety one of
the most trusted news sorts in
entertainment not me he claims I've lied
about him not paying his nanny or
getting DUIs I have not made these
claims I am reading them from
well-sourced and respected articles does
he not fund the New York Times reputable
reputation reputable and I'm glad he
posted these that was awesome you know
financer in Hollywood strikes dealing
DWI
that was awesome that he showed the
headlines of these you know Catch and
Release yes says money man
here's the title Hollywood financier is
arrested again New York Times
so again huge shout out to Philadelphia
for posting these because that that's
important what about variety Fair
there's also the disability fair this is
a quote from Vanity Fair there's also
the matter of two driving arrests he has
accrued since driving
since he has a cruise through 2006 both
suspected of DUIs the second while he
was still on probation for the first
to quote the article Mr Kavanaugh was
arrested by a sheriff's department
officer who accused him of driving under
the influence of alcohol and being
involved in a hit and run accident
that's Vanity Fair here this article
here is that defamation to read a
[ __ ] article the theory of relativity
by Vanity Fair
he has a problem with their reporting
taken up with them not me what about Fox
News Hollywood Executives sued by
babysitter and wage spat again Fox News
I'm reading headlines
again I'm not creating any of these
claims but merely reading was already
been published by well-respected news
sources how is that defamation Ryan
Kavanaugh claims that I have been paying
hordes of editors and Bots every
negative comment any bad review he
blames solely on me and not the cause of
his own poor Behavior he claims I'm
solely responsible for everyone's star
review Thrillers received despite
one of trailer stars and Equity holders
Noah back making a tick tock complaining
about the app being flipped
this video was posted to the trailer app
itself
thank you
trailer my thing's flipped they're now
Infamous my camera's like flipped around
right now but look
I'm I'm trying uh it's so awkward what
is it doing hey guys like look it's when
I put it this way oh I see it yeah weird
it's like mirrored damn should I head
off
yeah
good stuff
great app you got there
you know I have repeatedly mentioned to
only give honest engineering reviews of
trailer yet the biggest hyperbole in
this article comes in this line Ryan
Kavanaugh is the 26th highest grossing
movie producer
well that may be true who is keeping
track he fails to mention that he
utterly bankrupted his production
company relativity media
see that's the line he took out
here's a quote for you from Hollywood
Reporter and again I'm super proud of
Philly and happy that he read this hedge
fund investor Carrie Metz tells a
bankruptcy judge in a town full of scam
artist posers and false prophets and
Flim Flam men Ryan Kavanaugh is a
Hollywood Class by Himself
Hollywood Reporter Ryan Kavanaugh is
lampooned as relativity investors seek
fraud lawsuit alive
Ryan Cavanaugh is executive once forced
to document claiming that his then
president sexually harassed people so he
could fire him without paying him
Severance the judge found that it was
completely completely falsified in a
forensic analysis revealed the last
person at the document was a username
cavcv variety
deadline
this was reporting a variety of deadline
is is it now defamation to read an
article
Ryan Kavanaugh is a business Elite he
was you who's used to suing harassing
and breaking the law with no consequence
he wields the legal system like a
malignant Tyrant and uses it to silence
his critics now to stifle fair use
something we should all on YouTube care
about so okay he read a lot of it
he did a good job representing me so I'm
very thankful so give birth so give
Philly some birthday love we love that
man skinny oh I have this website open
still
[ __ ]
so
I I think I figured out where he was
getting the 26 highest grossing movie
producer of all time thing there is a
separate listing on
um the numbers that same website for top
grossing executive producers Stan Lee at
the domestic box office so this is like
a very specific beta
is they calling Ryan a beta
but here's what's weird he's number 28
not number 26.
liar see
so I mean maybe there's another even
more specific like top grossing
executive producers of the domestic box
office with red hair that he made he
might be he might even know yeah he
could be right up there well Ron Howard
for sure exactly so you wouldn't even
stop that one yeah how about executive
producers with red hair that's people
sometimes confused with Harvey Weinstein
based on appearance a lot that
occasionally it might be three that
occasionally operate a motor vehicle
under the influence of
allegedly Dan I think a Jerry
Bruckheimer would also be on that list
right yeah yeah so you might have been
up that one yeah
by the way Stan Lee's number one that's
crazy like okay that just goes to show
you how this is an exact producer on
anything that he created which is like
most of the Marvel Universe I'm saying
that just goes to show you how legit
this uh list is yeah
Stanley
all right well that's basically the show
um let me go to the comp let me read
some comments maybe there's interact
with the
the pooper Troopers
yeah I just want again want to thank all
you guys for
coming and supporting us and you know
caring about this because it's not an
easy thing to get involved in and I just
really appreciate y'all really um people
are spamming uh in fact they just got
timed out for spamming sorry about that
don't spam but I did see your message
that um that they really wanted us to
see the deaf noodles uh covered the
story as well [ __ ] it I'll watch it oh
and by the way people are saying um to
get Emily on I think she's going to call
in on Friday to go over the spiritual
complaint yeah it made more sense for
there to actually be a legal document to
uh people are shouting Sean a lot of
that thank you guys for all the love I
mean so much that you guys are here
supporting us and the most important
Battle of my life I would say this is
everything I mean everything's on the
line I stand to lose everything
and YouTube fair use stands to die on
this [ __ ] Hill
is that um
is that deaths
yeah okay great let's see what def's got
to say about it
wait when did this come out
nine hours ago oh
shoot again yeah you can do it again you
can always blame the haters for this
anyway moving on to Ethan Klein who is
once again getting sued by trailers Ryan
Kavanaugh now Ryan shared two
screenshots of legal filings on his
Instagram showing that he is currently
suing uh Ethan and Ethan's production
company for defamation and Ryan also
published this article discussing the
situation the dark side of the power of
social media why I Ryan Kavanaugh Sue to
Ethan Klein and his H3 podcast today I
sued Ethan Klein he has lied to his
followers in the public and profited
from it I was left with no choice but to
do exactly what he has told his millions
of fans I did prior sue him uh yes folks
the only way to resolve any kind of
dispute is to take it straight to court
and spend an exorbitant amount of money
or something absolutely frivolous in
fact the more lawsuits you file and the
more frivolous they are the better it is
anyway folks this appears to be the
third lawsuit that Ryan has filed
against Easton in the H3 podcast the
first one being for copyright where Ryan
claims that Ethan and the podcast
allegedly high rated the live stream
which if any of you have watched h3's
broadcast about that fight Not only was
it days after the fight actually
happened but it was completely under
fair use because they were just reacting
and commenting
that's all you got to say that's thank
you for saying that you know what I mean
Dennis like there's no there's no need
for like fence sitting I feel like it's
like it's obviously
Ryan Kavanaugh just filed his third
lawsuit against me dude is reaching
Scientology level of illegal harassment
and I'm getting so over it I mean at
this point the guy must just love to
burn money because I don't understand
how uh
filing lawsuits like this Ryan Kevin I
was trying to get my channel banned from
YouTube a powerful media person who has
gone to every length to destroy me for
criticizing him everyone needs to pay
attention now not only is fair use on
the line but powerful trying to shut
down channels for criticism now Ethan is
referring to something that Ryan
Kavanaugh wrote in his Instagram story
which said H3 Productions needs to stop
harassing harming and attempting to
destroy other people's lives spreading
false and malicious lies unfortunately
it looks like I'm going to have to be
the one to stop him I believe within a
month his channel will be banned from
YouTube now how much of a [ __ ] do you
have to be to pick a fight with someone
and then resort to trying to silence
them when they start responding and
standing up for themselves I mean I've
lost my Twitter account I've been there
there's no reason for me [ __ ] losing
my Twitter account to this [ __ ] day
I've actually spoken to Twitter
employees and they don't even know why
the [ __ ] my Twitter account was taken
down now I have my suspicions so trust
me I know a [ __ ] move when I see one
this one absolutely
well stated death noodles the dude knows
how to spit facts only no printers
proclaims to be Ryan Kavanaugh said he
has sent legal notices to YouTube and
twist to get me banned this person also
said a third lawsuit would be filed this
week which leads me to believe it is
actually Ryan how is it possible that
this guy can't stop snitching on himself
Ryan also sent me this threatening DM on
Instagram Ethan I'm not sure why you
have decided to take it upon yourself
and you showed him a line attacks Lander
and defamy I do not know you I also
don't know why you're spending thousands
of dollars to have thousands of dummy
accounts post fake statements about me I
can't folks I'm just exhausted at this
point cleanser yeah okay love it
um thank you
yeah I mean on one hand like doing a
GoFundMe would be awesome because it
would just piss him off to no end
knowing he's like I wasn't even spending
my own money but on the other hand
people like keemstar will make the whole
thing not worth it they'll turn it into
a whole controversy yeah and just make
me regret ever even uh accepting help
from you guys
which is why selling merch is probably
the best way Merchant just continue to
watch and support the show watch support
remember being a member being a member
is awesome yeah you know
um buying Teddy fresh downloaded donated
uh donated
1090 and okay is that uh Norwegian
should be around 100 bucks thank you
Alexander this is a little something for
the defense fund the memes was flow the
meme
keep the memes hit the floor that means
Hit the Floor
oh 120 bucks what a legend what a legend
yeah I'm not gonna do the GoFundMe it's
just it's gonna be very regrettable it's
going to turn into a little [ __ ] show of
all these [ __ ] tier commentary channels
talking about what a greedy piece of
[ __ ] I am and stuff it's not worth it
took it took years to uh finally
murderer
about the original one I know it did we
should do a new merch drop specifically
for this but supporting Teddy fresh
becoming a member just watching the show
it's all good even you know like you
know
news I don't know like Philly D covering
is awesome more people talking about is
awesome
I'd love to see some traditional media
people uh you know talk about it you
know Hollywood Reporter is that that's a
pretty big deal at least within the
entertainment no I agree that's that's
on the same level as variety like
Hollywood Porter and variety or 100 I
agree that's huge yeah
it's huge
um
but thank you guys I love to see how
y'all are so
um
you guys are the best I know what to say
it's it's awesome it's overwhelming it's
beautiful thank you guys for your
support on this because I'll tell you
what last night I was so I was [ __ ]
feeling bad I was worried I couldn't
sleep
you know and I just felt like sometimes
it just feels like I'm alone in it like
the last time it was there was so many
people involved that this time coming
here and seeing more people and seeing
all you guys supporting me
the amount of support I saw him like
when the third lawsuit was filed on the
subreddit was like all about
uh the the
um
the lawsuit and I was like it's so it's
it I felt much better this morning
I feel much better this morning seeing
all the support so thank you guys so
much and also I feel better actually
because I got real worried when I saw
this lawyer they hired this guy and once
I actually browse the complaint I still
haven't read it
I felt a little better because I wasn't
quite sure what they were going to have
in there
but once I saw was all about the Ponzi
thing I was like right I just read the
article
yeah I don't know it just seems like
such a stretch but
we'll see I don't know this guy is a
merciless he's aggressive so it's gonna
be a [ __ ] fight all the way to the
end this third one is going to be of
scrap all the way
to the end it's going to be a [ __ ] show
which [ __ ] sucks but it is what it is
family family family family family
family family family family family
family family family
yeah maybe Family Fun Vin Diesel and
family what are we saying Dan
um
so the first two lawsuits are are likely
to be concluded relatively soon
regardless of what happens with this
third right so today actually the judge
is going to rule on the
pseudo-defamation
uh
tortious interference one the second one
that was number two right so she she's
set to role in that today oh interesting
which I'm feeling very hopeful for the
copyright one I'm feeling very hopeful
for but it got delayed the hearing got
delayed until like uh
sometime next year early next year right
like February or something so we won't
hear anything from that one for a few
months but if we take the dub today on
that one it's going to give us a lot of
momentum I feel like sure so
fingers crossed I'm feeling hopeful I
feel like you know we did great motions
and pleadings my lawyers did a great job
I feel like the law the facts the whole
damn things on our side and
the judge who's really smart and
intuitive and her comments so far have
been really good so
we'll know on Friday actually if we're
going to take the dub on that one cool
family I love you guys so much and thank
you to all I mean this you know it just
means the world that I've actually got
um
people saying class action against Ryan
from the H3 family that's hilarious
yeah he has defamed you guys he's called
you guys Bots
yeah class action lawsuit from H3 family
which is honest it's so insulting to
love
to use that as a uh in a disparaging way
that's slur
yeah well how do you feel about being
profiled like that love bot
I mean I haven't done anything to Ryan
Kavanaugh there are there you know than
just existing so I don't know why you
gotta go to people like that that's
[ __ ]
so I'm not feeling very good about that
yeah I don't blame you it's like
you know what's next you're gonna throw
you in camps and [ __ ] yeah I mean I did
I did do that suck my dick joke on him
oh you think he's still holding a grudge
for this yeah guys are pretty good yeah
he did end up blocking me too so
you shouldn't [ __ ] with them on social
media I reject that love yeah I said
sorry to him afterwards yeah
don't do that nobody [ __ ] with Ryan on
social media that's against
oh so Cam said he blocked me and all I
said was check for corn what does that
mean check for corn
it's just referencing Zach's uh little
poop meme oh my thirst trap Tick Tock
when we were doing wait he's familiar
with the check for corn meme like how
could he know I don't know
don't do that Cameron
don't leave comments on his social media
yeah he's blocked
you know
not to mention this is emotional harmful
as a viewer it's hurting me we should
sue this isn't okay
well
it is man I was me I was so stressed bro
and I was like trying not to stress Ela
out she's massive she can barely walk at
this point you know
well she's got a lot of back pain from
the pregnancy all right that's why we
got the bed out for her right and I just
I don't want to stress her out with this
stuff but I didn't want to lead on how
stressed I was yesterday I was I
couldn't sleep I was just thinking
[ __ ] I was thinking like ma'am
my the darkest thoughts I had last night
was like
did I [ __ ] you know did I take this too
far did I [ __ ] this up should I just pay
them the 100th or the
million apparently not a million yeah
should I just pay it offered more money
to them to make this go away
or the darkest thought is like are they
gonna win and take everything I have am
I gonna lose my house
you know because I was reading about
this this lawyer
and they're like he won law uh
defamation lawsuits with and won 10
million dollar verdicts and [ __ ] like
that so I was like okay well
if I lose am I going to lose every like
am I gonna [ __ ] have to sell my house
and like pay them
so those were my darkest thoughts and
that's just being real that's what I'm
worried about
well you can't take your family they can
never take my family family
family families
he's gonna be like you're gonna flip
this and be like they're part of a cult
what were you saying Dan
that we could all move to Rio and you
know start doing high stakes heists of
Banks and [ __ ] oh that'd be cool yeah
[ __ ] yeah dude
have the rock chase us try and Hunt us
down but we're always one step ahead I'm
reading all the comments guys cap needs
to be careful with frivolous lawsuits a
joke could restrict his right to sue and
future potential lawsuits yeah I mean
I don't know anything about that it's
out
oh God the families are going crazy in
the chat yeah we all family dog
um
uh what was I gonna say yeah you would
think that there would be more
repercussions for misusing the legal
system like this but I don't I'm not
super familiar with
but I know like the Church of
Scientology sues people for no reason
like 50 times and drowns them so
I'm I'm just not familiar with the
with the law
but um
that's it eh
that's it yeah so family speaking of
family
is being moved to next week next week
record it on Wednesday for the off the
rails slot for the week
and then tomorrow we're doing it's then
it's a normal week other than that yeah
but we'll come back overs tomorrow yeah
off or not off the rails uh after dark
on Friday the chat is going so fast with
families I'm trying to read comments
look what we started
I love how it keeps going on about you
paying Bots but in reality we are paying
you just to support and watch here to
support the fund as well thank you
Marina I don't know what a c h f is but
it's 55. should Kim something maybe
family
Cafe
um there's a Swiss franc
a Swiss franc
54 us thank you so much what's your
Linda
but I'm trying to catch comments we're
going so fast cat just mad because he's
not part of the family
true
facts all facts all right well I gotta
go um
the rest of my voice check on Ela
oh
that's stressful I I didn't expect it to
hit me as hard as it did because like
these previous two I was like pretty
like we're gonna do this we're gonna
beat this it's gonna be fine
I think it was the fact that he hired
this lawyer that like freaked me out
definitely and I was reading about him
and all the and I was like
oh [ __ ] you know
fun
but there ain't no turning back now
here we go
family oh the battery died it was on
this whole time oh no it's still on
family family family family family
family
wait wait hold on family oh
family family family family
oh no Dan is transforming to Vin Diesel
family family family
family family family family family
family family family family family
family family family family family
family family family family family
thank you
[Music]